this is jocko podcast number 256
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening and
joining us once again
is dave burke good evening dave good
evening
and tonight we are going to wrap
the final installment on guidelines for
the leader and commander by general
bruce clark this is the subject of
podcasts
plural 251 252 253 254
255 and now finally 256.
so much to learn taking the lessons that
were passed on to
colonel david hackworth who served
degree in vietnam
wrote the book about face taught me many
leadership lessons well he learned those
lessons
from this book written by general bruce
clark who served in korea
world war ii world war one
who led many soldiers trained even more
including one that he didn't even know
about
me
and we are trying to pass those lessons
on so for the
final installment let's get back to the
book
guidelines for the leader and commander
chapter 11 physical conditioning there
you go echo charles
i'm sure your interest just got peaked
here we go
i would like to pass on to you for such
implementation as may be
practicable within your several commands
and within your various types of
headquarters and units some thoughts on
the problem of physical exercise
physical condition
and physical training this is a complex
subject
its success depends on the program each
commander works out
to fit his needs and facilities and then
enthusiastically and energetically
pushes
while many of our units and individuals
are in fine physical shape
this is not universally true in many
commands
i believe it can be made more nearly
universally true
by a more general concept as to its
importance
and to a consideration of the
implementation of practical steps
that can be taken in this field without
materially interfering
with our other activities what grade are
you giving
general clark for simplicity on that
whole opening i'm not giving him a good
grade
luckily he redeemed you're going to see
he redeems himself from the end of this
book with some
real simple clear concise
so he thinks that you know the simple
statement is people should be working
out
i believe strongly that good physical
condition is one of the evidences
of a spree in a unit as well as of
morale
in an individual so it helps both your
team and you as a person
now here's where we have a serious beef
serious beef probably one of the most
serious beefs ever
for me with general clark
this topic is called calisthenics at end
of day
echo you're probably going to want to
throw down with this one
you're going to throw in with him on one
occasion i visited a unit and observed
calisthenics being conducted during the
first period of the morning
this was being done in the normal way by
a junior sergeant conducting the
exercises
with the senior non-commissioned
officers and officers
standing around to supervise and monitor
possibly the ones who needed the
exercise the most were the ones
observing
that's a good one right you don't want
to be that guy you don't want to be that
guy that's standing there with uh
small arms telling people they need to
do more pull-ups right
you don't want to find yourself in that
situation no sir i did not
but then he says this i do not think
calisthenics or other physical training
exercise
in the first hour of the day is good of
course as we know
i definitely think that working out the
first hour of the day is good
if they are done strenuously enough to
be of any value
so that the men work up perspiration the
men then wear
the same wet clothes throughout the day
or until such clothing dries on them
similarly if men perform exercises
requiring them to sit on the ground or
lie on the ground
they start off the day with dirty and
maybe wet clothing now for me general
clark all due respect
i think we can just take a shower and
change clothes when we're done working
out yeah
i think we can overcome that in the
modern era
yeah i gotta admit that kind of
surprised me as being the first reason
that he's talking about yeah why not to
work out first thing in the morning yeah
because
we we could just we could just shower
seems easy to solve that problem
i will say this though i think he's
coming from a time period where
they didn't have this full like this was
only an idea that was just coming to
fruition right so it wasn't a thing yet
yeah it wasn't a thing to work out so
people didn't have
workout clothes people didn't have
workout
shoes people didn't have workout
bag you know these people didn't have a
workout bag they didn't have your
the little freaking reebok bag or
whatever that echo charles takes the
24-hour
fitness get your curls on
yes so they didn't have that back then
so he's thinking hey you show up to work
and the first thing we're gonna do is
build up a sweat now we're gonna
wet the clothes all day all right we'll
give you we'll cut you some slack
and then he says i believe it is far
more reasonable to devote the last hour
in the afternoon to physical exercising
and physical training
so that the men can go from it to the
showers
and get into other clothing for supper
and the evening
this is the time when the mind is tired
and training requiring mental attention
is least effective
okay so that's okay so all right so we
we're just gonna jump past like all the
whole thing about
when you're working out because i think
it's just i think we're beyond that now
in the modern era
yeah i don't think we're i think we can
work out whenever it makes the most
sense not based on our
sweat and clothing can we put that can
we set that one aside
i agree yes we can so now this is
interesting
this is the time when the mind is tired
and training requiring mental attention
is least effective
doesn't it take a certain level of
mental
effort to do a hard workout yeah
don't don't you think yes dave
yes i wonder if he's thinking like
intellectual effort
right i get that and i get that too like
for instance this might sound stupid
uh when i'm going to when i'm going to
let's say it's late at night and i'm
like tired
and i've got some more reading to do
i'll read until i'm just gonna fall
asleep and then i'll get up brush my
teeth whatever
take my supplements as echo likes to say
so i'll do my little evening routine
floss
every day and then and then i'll have
like you know i stood up so now i'm i
can read a little bit longer i can go a
little bit longer
and then i go to sleep so when you do
something
i guess that what i'm saying is you get
bored so maybe this is a good plan hey
it's the end of the day
you're kind of tired you don't feel like
focusing on this what you call it dave
intellectual work effort yeah yeah you
don't you don't you you've spent your
intellectual energy but you can still
just go jack some steel
possibly okay i
don't know i don't agree think that
that's the case
for some of us that like no man when
you're mentally
exhausted i mean sure there are some
circumstances but as a general
sort of way an approach to working out i
don't know man i don't know if i can get
there quite yet
okay but we'll see so you want to have
you want to be mentally fresh
for your workout yes okay
all right back to the book in two
divisions and in a brigade in which i
served everyone
stopped activities at four o'clock on
two days a week
with the exception of the necessary duty
officers guards and everyone at the from
the commanding general
everyone from the commanding general on
down took physical exercises
this physical exercising consisted of
activities that provided a real workout
none of this echo charles
real workout certain well-organized
selected games were allowed
provided that everyone played organized
calisthenics were allowed
but the bulk of the units engaged in a
four mile trot
and fast walk to to be completed in 50
minutes
yeah so bro we're talking 12 minute
miles or whatever we're not this is not
this is not a challenge and here's what
here as i thought through this it
started to make a little bit more sense
combat boots with proper socks worn by
all personnel in order to get the men
used to
and prevent damage to their feet right
above the top of the boots everyone's
permitted to prescribe their own uniform
within the realm of decency
this gave men a feeling of freedom which
added to the relaxation and benefit of
exercise okay so that's cool
i do not think this lack of uniformity
hurt the discipline of the unit
it was not a show men tr
men traveled the previously laid out
four mile courses
as individuals being checked at the
start and finish
to record their times in order to
motivate the slow ones by falling
so this is just we you know he just kind
of prescribes this weird like
four mile walk that everyone's gonna go
on
which tells me
earlier when i said they weren't that
working out wasn't really like a thing
yet
yeah it wasn't yeah because if they're
thinking 50 minutes and four miles
but the only thing i can say about that
also is if you're talking about a whole
division or a whole brigade of people
like these are not
all frontline soldiers obviously these
are
administrative people and whatever
the general himself so yeah i don't know
um by following the course as
individuals instead of for formation no
one exercised so strenuously as to do
himself damage regardless of his
physical condition or
age care should be taken in starting
such
a program to work into it reasonably so
as not to increase
the sick call rate i you i think if you
look if you imagine like a corporation
like a giant corporation a division size
corporation with whatever
10 or 15 000 people and they were gonna
start a physical training
program this might be an okay program
you got 50 minutes
you got to go out you got to move four
miles go for a walk whatever i think
that's
i think that's almost the perspective
that he's coming from
okay
i don't know though because didn't he
just say a real workout
and there should be sweating i mean i'm
not sweating after a after 12-minute
miles
for four miles and i sweat a lot as you
know
well let's just be thankful that we are
where we are
where where we've learned so much about
physical training
and which has changed a lot i mean did
you see that picture i post and the
other day of
i was like yelling at one of my friends
back in the day and he's doing
cable crossovers i couldn't tell what he
was doing
crazy but he was doing just cable
crossovers
yeah oh yeah hard core building
sculpting the chest
building the what the lower packs
leave it to you to try to yell at him
while he's doing that exercise too it's
not like he was doing deadlifts
i think we were just messing around
actually uh physical exercise program
the secretary of the army has written to
commanders about the tendency to to move
troops from barracks to work and from
barracks to training areas by vehicle
instead of
marching them when it is practicable to
march
he pointed out that it's very important
that the troops retain the ability to
march and especially
was and this was especially important in
mechanized
and motorized armor units so that's a
great point
when you have the opportunity to march
instead of riding a vehicle you should
march instead of riding a vehicle
that's one thing that's cool about buds
in buds you run to dan you run to
breakfast and back you're on the lunch
and back you run the dinner and back
it's a mile there it's a mile back so
you're doing six miles a day
before anything like before the day
before you get credit for anything you
ran six miles
yeah as a pilot
do you because i was watching some
videos of some pilots you know
that i came across um and do you guys
like
kind of have to stay in physical
condition just to endure
like flying a plane essentially i mean
the physical fitness standards are
universal across the marine corps all
the same
there is a there's a unique
level of fitness that is associated with
flying and it kind of comes and goes
with how much flying you're doing
but there's not like a separate type of
aviation fitness other than
there are things about aviation that
will fatigue you that you you won't get
fatigued doing other things and and
that's true for other things as well
but like the pt in the marine corps
doesn't they don't care what your
your job is okay can you train for
the like let's say you did a
disassociated tour and you weren't
flying for
18 months and now you knew you were
going back to a squadron you're gonna be
fine
is there any exercises that you could do
to get ready
for flying you can't train for g
tolerance which is like the big thing so
that's like it's a perishable thing
you know there's there's uh you know
aerobic and anaerobic there's certain
muscles that are good
to be strengthened um but if you haven't
flown
it's the g's that will that you cannot
train for you can't replicate those g's
and you can't train for those g's
at all i mean okay let me challenge you
now you can train for the technique
and you can strengthen the muscles to do
that but you can't replicate
the actual feeling of the jeez but that
being said
if you take someone that's in really
good shape versus someone that's not
really good shape the person that's in
really good shape is gonna do better
maybe i mean okay
i mean you have to use your muscles yeah
you you do but
like larger muscles don't don't mean
better g
tolerance but what about just
conditioning yeah no absolutely yes
a better conditioned person is going to
be able to endure
all things being equal be able to endure
the rigors of flying more than the other
person but that doesn't mean he's going
to have a higher g tolerance
did i ever tell you about my my buddy
when my platoons all went backseat in
the f-18s
so we went through the whatever training
you go through so you can get called to
go the back seat
so we all go through well he showed up
late and so he missed the whole briefing
on how to what is it called how to
push the blood to your brain he missed
all that
and then he missed whatever and then he
showed up i think he was out i think he
was drinking the night before
and so there's a little covered move and
like we snuck him back into the class
and put his name on the roster and it's
all good
well then he showed he go we get up to
fallon
and he didn't know what to do he just
got in the plane he's like cool i know
you know whatever and he passed out the
entire time you know he would just like
wake up
and then just pass out again because he
didn't know to to
put the blood to his head he didn't know
to do that so he's just passing out
and they had video of it does that make
sense that they had video of it totally
he was just
he was just flopping around in the
cockpit
and we were laughing and he's like i had
no idea he didn't remember anything he
was just passing out yep
bro can't you get like hurt like that
like if you're passed out all limp and
catch your neck because you know those
that video that you play
at the muster of that guy in the what do
you call those centrifuges yeah
yeah and he he passes out and it's like
probably still getting smashed from the
force yeah
i don't think there's any real risk of
permanent injury from doing that it's
more just
being humiliated but yeah all right
yeah that actually that's what i was
that's what i meant like do you guys
train do you guys have a specific like
training routine
for that because man it you don't really
realize that i mean maybe you do maybe
don't you know but
when you see guys flying planes and
doing all that stuff you don't really
understand like what you're going
through physically
in there you know right is there an
ideal physical build
for fighter pilot i don't think so man
i mean just like with every marine
they're just all shapes and sizes i mean
my my body type is drastically different
than others
and if you were going to be an f-18
pilot or let's say an f-35 pilot yeah
you were going to design an f-35 pilot
human yeah
how tall would that human be six foot
how much how much would they weigh 190
pounds so that's it just like
so there is an ideal that's because if
he's six four he's
cramped in the cockpit if he's six if
he's five
five he can't reach the pedals or
whatever
right i mean there's issues there are
there are legitimate
anthropometric issues that is achieved
like you get measured all these odd
measurements like
ankle or like elbow to wrist like ankle
to knee there's all sorts of
physical measurements the the window is
pretty broad
and even you know for me to say six foot
190 i'm just talking about like
a lean strong guy does that mean a five
foot six 125 pound person can't be a
good pilot no they totally absolutely
can absolutely can would that person
maybe struggle a little bit with like
looking over their shoulder yeah they
would their body type is if you're 6'4
and you're banging your head against the
canopy which
guys in my squadron guys whose call
signs were stretched because they were
so tall
at the end of the day i don't think
anyone would come back and say i'm
better because of my build or my height
so even that answer is like the window
is broad enough to say that anybody and
there's pilots out there
plenty of good pilots out there that
aren't six foot 190. is there is there a
cutoff
height or minimum technically yeah i
think it's pretty small i think it's
it's very short like five one five two
you know you can accommodate someone
that short and i think
i i've known guys that are six five six
six flying fighters so damn they get
it there's a big window in there
do they call them pedals they do they
call them pedals
they're adjustable so the image of not
being able to reach the pedals is more
funny than anything
but i'll tell you what as a as a taller
guy you know a taller
dude and you know when you get into an
airplane that somebody else has flown
and they're on the
the shorter side you get in your your
knee you know it's like being in the
backseat of a car and you immediately
have to push those pedals all the way
back because the dude in front of you is
way shorter than you so it's adjustable
like a cadillac
it is it's the adjustment is not too far
away from the
the cockpit temperature adjuster oh
that's right so you know you can adjust
that little temperature
jack all right going on i do not wish to
discourage anyone who gets exercise from
golf tennis bowling
hunting fishing gardening walking skiing
etc
in fact i encourage such activities
during off time
when spring arrives and long daylight
hours of the year are with us it's good
time to start physical training program
he goes on a commander should have no
objection to
cl to the closing of any headquarters at
four o'clock two days a week in order to
devote this time to physical exercising
nor should he object to the stopping of
other activities in most
toe units at four o'clock two afternoons
a week
for this purpose so he's talking about
you should always train two days a week
which once again
i mean yeah in the marine corps you guys
do pt every single day right well not
aviation units
all the time yeah i mean when i was with
the ground units that was every single
day
and there was a time allocated to that
um
the squadrons that i would in i was in
didn't do five days a week
five day week pt huh i thought that was
pretty standard
in the whole military well that's what
he's saying he's saying only two days a
week
yeah i mean i think what he's saying
it's interesting because you mentioned
the comment this guy was
you know steeped in world war one this
is a guy saying
you need to prioritize time for pt now i
mean
two days a week now looking back as you
know reflecting on that but
he was probably a pioneer saying hey
commanders shut your unit down to go
work out yeah and you should do that
like that's okay as opposed to
hey we got to get this paperwork done or
this whatever other thing going on is so
he might have been out in front of the
curve for all i know for the for the era
that he was in saying
it's okay from the general down to the
private does it shut down normal ops
to go to unit no absolutely i you're 100
i believe you're 100 right he was the
guy that was
spearheading working out look you got to
get out there two days a week
he doesn't even say minimum right
because that would be sort of like hey
minimum two days a week he's just saying
two days a week like you gotta get out
there
um in connection with this physical
exercise program i think we might well
give thought to delaying
the evening meal on monday through
friday in order to give the men more
time to get cleaned up showered
and dressed so they will not feel the
urge to rush right to work
well right from work to supper this was
this the reason i wanted to read the
sections this would have advantages
other than physical conditioning
by serving the evening meal in the
enlisted messes as early as we do
we leave the soldier with over six hours
of time after supper
before he is scheduled to be in bed to
do things that sometimes lead to trouble
more exercise in a later meal hour in
the afternoon would tend to reduce free
time in the evening
and would absorb energies and would
encourage the men to go to bed earlier
it has been found to be an overall
advantage to serve the heavy meal at
night instead of at noon
on duty days i believe we give enough
time off to our food service people so
they can live with these changes
in the feeding program
oh it's so classic
alcohol i've written before chapter
three about the
intemperate use of alcohol and the and
of the desirability of cutting down
on the quantity of consumption of
alcohol one of the reasons for this
is to help improve the physical
condition of our officers and men
obesity i would like to say a word about
personnel being overweight
while there are not very many
such personnel in most commands there
are some who are eating more than their
physical activity burns up
the commander should bring this to the
attention of such individuals with a
view
to more exercising or less eating or
both
other pro problems
and this is the last section other
problems this is just a broad statement
this is this
this is actually something that echo
that you used to say all the time
on this podcast other problems i believe
that such a program as i suggested will
automatically help to solve the problem
in those units which have one
of men and garrison changing out of
fatigues for evening social activities
it should help reduce other unfavorable
statistics as well
you used to say on this podcast all the
time echo that
the most universally helpful
thing that a person can do is exercise
it will help you in all aspects of
whatever you're doing
which is a good point and what he's
saying is hey if you exercise
you every problem that you have is going
to be improved
there you go so echo was the pioneer on
that one
there's something you said i was
thinking about in my my contrast between
aviation my my time
in a fighter squadron versus my time at
anglica which is kind of the biggest
contract
uh contrast is and i don't know how it
is elsewhere but
the infantry or the ground units when i
was with them have a kind of
pre-regiment like their day is a it's
kind of a typical work day
whereas a fighter squadron operates 24
hours a day so they're
they are running in shifts the whole
time so standard work week is there's
always a third or a half of the unit
there
from sunday night to friday afternoon so
that cycle is a little it's i was kind
of
thinking in my head just the the the you
getting the whole unit together in
a squadron almost never happens you're
at best you're going to have
like even when you're doing your work up
you running that workup is a
workup is probably even worse because
workups you know your the flying
schedule shifts around a bunch to get
all these different calls
but you i would say routinely
the best you're ever going to get is
half your squadron there at any given
time most of the time now it's not
always like that but i would say
90 of a typical fighter squadron cycle
is
you have two or three shifts and you'll
never have more than half your squadron
there at any given time well before the
war
in the 90s at the team we used to pt as
a team five days a week
yeah as a team maybe one day would be
what they call the individual pt which
guys would legitimately individual pt
they'd go do whatever would you know
do jiu jitsu or whatever they were gonna
do
but the other days it was like oh monday
is a run tuesday's a swim
wednesday's individual pt thursday's of
course friday's monster mash that was
kind of a typical st
schedule at the in the it's back in the
what's the monster match monster mash is
just of course
boat paddle just come up with some crazy
sort of various what would you call it i
don't know what you it'd be like one of
those um
you ever see those tv uh physical
competitions
where they're doing all these up like
you'd run the obstacle course then you
would do berm runs
but you would be in a little team so
it'd just be some kind i don't know we
called it a monster match
like american ninja warrior yeah like
american ninja warrior but as
teams gotcha and is the platoon back in
the this is obviously pre-war but back
in was
the platoon kind of together all the
time yeah so the platoon was together
but the team wasn't so there'd be two
platoons out in the desert there'd be a
though there'd be one platoon out of the
desert there'd be one platoon up a foul
and there'd be another platoon in
the jungle somewhere but there'd still
be three platoons back at the team and
all the support people from the team so
the platoon is like that was the
element that at the lowest level like
they were together you didn't really
break up platoons very often
not very often that's cool you're going
through your work up together but you
got to remember a seal platoon is small
right a seal platoon is only 16 guys
sometimes
in the past we bumped them up to 18
sometimes we've even bumped them up to
depending on manning and personnel and
mission
but the general seal platoon 16 people
and post post war did that become the
task unit was together
for the most part almost like elevate up
at the yes
then they all of a sudden they they made
the task unit
which is two platoons together with a
headquarters unit over it
and they and they had the idea it took
them a while to like actually
make it happen so there was some good
vision on the on behalf of
naval special warfare commanders
to say actually you know what we should
probably put a bigger unit together
because 16 guys is is very limiting
right what can you do with 16 guys i
mean
if you man up vehicles with 16 guys
you man up whatever you man up three
vehicles now you now there's six people
in those vehicles driver gunner driver
gunner driver gunner
you put the rest of the guys in that
gives you ten assaulters what can you
take down with tennis holders the answer
is not very many
so went into a task unit mode with now
you had two platoons plus you had
headquarters
and then you get attachments of eod and
maybe you get a
some kind of a radio man to help you out
so all of a sudden you know you got um
35 or 40 guys going out the door so it
turns into a
a better situation was a really good
call i remember one of the
one of the first things uh i was in a
platoon
i was in an arg platoon which meant we
were going out on a ship and we had to
do hydrographic reconnaissance which is
old school lead line and slate lead line
of sight meaning you had a lead line you
had a piece of rope
with a piece of lead on the bottom and
you you tied little knots
every six feet for fathoms and you would
go and swim in a line and dip that lead
line and see how deep the water was and
then you'd dive for obstacles before the
marines came in
this is world war ii straight up udt
underwater demolition team stuff
well when you're in the arc platoon you
actually did that a lot because you were
supporting marine corps landings
so so we were we had a 16-man platoon
and i didn't argue like that with 16
guys and it was really hard because you
have a
you have a boat party of guys and then
you have like a radio men so there's two
or three guys that aren't in the water
and somebody's staying with the boat so
there's another two guys that are
not in the water so all of a sudden
you've got you've only got
seven guys to do the recon or nine guys
to do the recon or whatever so that's
that's not good so i remember writing a
point paper
i was like an e4 and i wrote a point
paper to my commanding officer that the
arg platoons
should have four more personnel in the
platoon
and i think we actually got like they
gave us like two more guys
pretty cool young
i mean who did i think i was such a
it's pretty funny i look back at that
standard naval letter format when
i send it to you i know i tried yeah i
know i tried but the cool thing was you
know my commanding officer at the time
was like
yeah you know that makes sense hey we
can't give you four but we can give you
two
make it an 18-man platoon we had an
18-man platoon i'm pretty sure
i can't even remember you know what's
weird is i can't even remember
what yeah i can't remember if he gave us
two more people maybe gave us one more i
think he gave us at least one more
person because i think i know exactly
who it was
but anyways all right so there's the
physical conditioning thing
um the next section
is called chapter 12 the creating of
superior
units four basic principles i have found
that there are four basic principles
which apply to the problem of creating
army units which are considered
superior first
the superior unit must be created from
the ordinary
run of personnel
how awesome is that you're gonna make a
superior unit
but anybody that's ever served in the
military knows that you're gonna get
what you get
and yet we all know that there's units
that are freaking awesome and there's
units that are horrible
and both the awesome units and the
horrible units
have run-of-the-mill people in them they
came from the they come from the same
pool of soldiers in this case it's all
the same people you don't get to pick
your
little team of your superstar athletes
in this case
uh and it's the same thing in business
right it's the same thing in business
you get
businesses that are in the same market
and one of them is crushing and the
other one's not
well why is that why is that you're both
getting to hire from the same
group of human beings and in the country
whatever country you're in
so the superior unit must be created
from the ordinary run of personnel
second
classified according to ability the men
in a unit fall naturally into three
groupings
upper middle and lower the excellence of
a unit
depends upon the ability of the
commander to bring the men of the lower
group to a degree of proficiency
which makes them an asset to his unit
team
so this is we're going to get into some
stuff where i'm
i'm not sure about i'm not sure about
this is one of them and he talks about a
little bit more i mean he talks about
your focus being making the people that
are he's basically saying you got good
really good people
middle people and bad people he's saying
the focus is like make the bad people
better
make the bad people a a a plus for the
unit
i don't necessarily agree with that i i
agree with that
should be ah focus a singular focus
i don't think it should be the full i
would rather take my people that are at
the top
and make them totally awesome and make
my people that are in the middle like
really really good
i'm not going to focus my efforts on the
turds
the reason i didn't say anything when
you when you read that because i had
that little like
is i'm going to listen what general
clark has to say
before i but but at on its face that
when you said that
my first thinking was was okay i don't
think that's right but
um obviously he's gonna say something
about it but we
we get this question in business all the
time leaders will devote
all their attention to their bottom
performers like almost all of their
attention it's like
why would you invest all of your time in
your least productive people
why wouldn't you invest most of your
most of your time in your most
productive people
again you don't you don't ignore those
people but if you're devoting and again
he's going to say something i'm sure
yeah yeah but when you said that i had
that reaction of
well it's like if you let's say on a on
a
level of one to five you're a five
and echo's a one one being the worst
five being the best of course so if i
take my efforts
and i'm able to i'm able to double
your power i can turn you into a ten i
can only turn echo into a two
exponentially positive returns on dave
burke
yeah kinda not honest
all right next third all men to des this
is such
this is such an interesting one
third all men desire to do what is
wanted of them
all men desire to do what is wanted
of them okay so that's that's the first
part so let's
let's absorb that and then he goes on
to just take some ownership here when
they do not
it is because they have not been
adequately motivated and
instructed so
have you ever had anybody in your
squadron that
straight up just didn't want to do what
was what was wanted of them
you know i would say yes in the sense
that
yeah there are people that i've had in
my units that fit that bill
and we did something about that
his point i understand his point though
and the idea that
that i'm going to write that person off
is unwilling to do it
to me it's it was more like how how much
of my ti how much energy am i gonna
devote to try to find the way that gets
you
to where i need to be so while i don't
disagree with that comment
yeah i've had people in my in my spirit
multiple times throughout my career
that simply didn't get where they needed
to be
and could you say hey that's for the
fault of the leader yes
100 but the leader also still has to
make a little measurement of
am i going to devote 100 of my time to
getting that guy from a one to a two
i'm gonna go hey man this investment in
you right now is going to take away from
all this other stuff and i'm going to
cut you loose yeah and by the way what's
what's
what's ten times zero yeah if the
person's a zero well now
you so so listen i think all men
is an overstatement i think you could
throw a percentage on there that's
upwards of 97
yeah 97 that want to
do what they want to do a good job they
want to do a good job
and to his point as a leader your
default should be
is they're not the problem your default
is the percentage is so high that you
might as well just go in the assumption
that the problem isn't with them so that
is i think actually correct not all
but i think his point too is like hey if
you're in charge of people and they're
not
they're not up to standards you need to
spend most of your time figuring out
what you're doing wrong yeah
most people don't need to be fired they
need to be led i think we wrote that in
extreme ownership or
in dichotomy of leadership i think it's
an economy leadership most people don't
need to be fired they need to be led
most people yeah all people no you're
going to get and you know what i
you know when you see this and i don't
well you didn't get to see this because
you were an
officer and you went through ocs
when you go through like navy boot camp
you see some people that don't want to
be there they do not want to be there
they're there for 15 minutes
like this ain't for me and they're going
to do whatever they got to do to get
they don't want to do what is wanted of
them
they don't yeah they want out
uh fourth the best unit in an
organization is always the one which is
excellent or better in all things
if you agree with these precepts let us
analyze and apply them
to the basic problem of the commander
who is striving for a superior unit
application to the units the
applications of the principles to the
unit
the problems of polishing ordinary units
until they emerge as superior are
primarily the problems of raising
individual performance and capabilities
to a superior level
the many truly outstanding units which
have been produced in our army
given give ample evidence that these
problems can be
solved
based on the fact that their percentile
scores on the
afqt which is like the asvab which is
the
it's the basic intelligence test that
you take when you're coming in the
military as an enlisted did you take it
to become an officer
yeah yeah yeah no i took it took the
asvab yes absolutely okay
so you take like a basic test it's sort
of uh
an sat and a ct type test totally how
smart
are you is basically what it is and then
he ranks it out into three groups
and it's the upper third the middle
third the lower third
but he's got this little thing in here
and he's got the scores listed and i'm
not gonna
uh go into those but the upper third
is 11 and 34. so the upper
the top two groups combined
make up 45 so 45 of people are in the
are in the 65 percentile and higher
of that testing 43 are in the middle so
you're almost done and then the last 12
is people that are in not the lowest
group
but the second the lowest group so if
you get between zero and nine
on the on the asvab and these aren't
this is this is actually
the afqt which is the old asvab so the
scores won't correlate to what
we know about since we didn't take the
asvab in 19th or we can take the asqt in
1958.
so what he's saying is you're going to
get mostly people
that are either in the middle group or
in the higher group which is great
now i'm sure that there's some people
that are thinking well that's the
difference you know
you know i'm in the civilian world and
we get these people they're they're not
no
when you start talking about people that
are in the lowest scoring brackets of
the
of the asvab like they they can't get in
the military but they're also
not gonna be applying for
a job with that's gonna take some some
high level
cognitive abilities they're just not
going to be there
so i've got a very interesting book that
i'm going to cover on the podcast and
and it's it's really it's
i've been reading it for a while i've
actually actually showed it to you
several months ago because i've been
stewing on it but it's during the
vietnam war
they they needed people
yeah they needed people to be in the
military
they needed people to be in the military
to go to vietnam and so
they started to lower the standards and
the the main standard that they lowered
was the the iq level or i don't know if
you want to call it the iq level but
that's basically what's the intellectual
level the
the the intelligence level and they
started getting these
these people in the military that were
just they just didn't have the mental
capacity to
to do really any job
um even and you know you know you think
about in the military there's some
pretty
there's some pretty there's some jobs
that don't take a lot of intellectual
horsepower
right i mean you need people that are
going to clean the the toilets you know
you got you got some
you know you got a people that are gonna
and look these are what we this is what
i did when i got the military right when
i got the seal teams i was cleaning
toilets
but then you you're gonna move up and
you're gonna move on but at some place
you need some people that are going to
have some pretty fundamentally
non-high cognitive skill
requirement jobs well they started
letting people in that this didn't have
the capability it's a really sad
and these guys a lot of these guys went
to vietnam they had obviously they had a
higher casualty rate they had a higher
more of them got killed uh because they
just didn't they just didn't
understand things and the guy that wrote
this book that i'm reading he went he's
talking about going through boot camp
and he basically gets paired up with one
of these guys
and all the drill instructors knew it
they they called them like mcnamara's
morons that's what they'd call these
guys when they come in
and he got assigned one of these guys
basically to to
to help get him through boot camp and
one of the most
like one of the opening scenes is
they're telling him
hey you know write write your address on
this postcard
and write a message to your family and
not only did he not know how to write
but he didn't even know what his address
was
he didn't even know what his what street
he lived on it didn't he didn't know
they had to teach him how to tie his
shoes and they had to teach him how to
tie his shoes not just hey this is how
you do it no like
they had to teach him for extended
periods of time
how to tie his shoes so these are people
that are really
in a car really you know in a low
intellectual level
and we we brought i think it was about a
hundred thousand of them into the
military which is just
uns just just horrible just horrible
um so my point in saying all that is
we're talking about you know you in in
the civilian sector
you're not getting that person either to
apply for your job in accounting right
so don't think to yourself well you know
my accounting department
that my guys my people are there they
don't they're not smart either no we're
not talking about that
we're not talking about that um
so he goes on to say that
those in the upper groupings are the
best educated and quickest to learn
can be well motivated but need to be
challenged to develop their full
potential
the middle groupings are average run of
american use they are easily controlled
take well to discipline learn easily
respond to good leadership but are
usually capable of more
and they must be pushed the lower
groupings are the ones that need special
attention and again this is where
you and i are kind of like the lower
groupings are the ones who need special
attention the disciplinary problem in
this group is
higher than average i agree with that
the individuals require special
motivation instruction
agree with that their attitude
constitutes
a special barometer of the esprit de
corps of the unit
this group contains also many of the
misfits
who if they cannot be assimilated
assimilated
must be eliminated so
it's interesting that that he's calling
for like special attention
on this lower group uh
and then he says in a single squad crew
go well
just i'm thinking in my mind as i'm
hearing you talk about this just
things that i've heard you say on this
podcast things we've talked about on
your podcast
and and i'm i'm trying to kind of
consider
what's in general clark's head as i'm
hearing this obviously i'm trying to put
myself in this position
you know we've talked about this before
and i think the way you said it was
anybody on your team has the potential
to undo your entire plan you know
and so i'm trying to make this
connection my head of the things he's
talking about why you devote
so much effort to these people and i'm
i'm just trying to place in my head why
he's saying it the way he's saying it
which there is if they're on your team
and you keep them on your team these
aren't people you get rid of but they're
on your team and they are
underperformers or low performance
they still have the potential of undoing
your plan
and so i'm trying to piece the things
that he's thinking almost i don't know
what he's going to say
but i do understand that you know the
flip side to that the other thing i've
been thinking about
we work with companies that some of the
companies we work with have this
philosophy is
hey we're going to pay more and we're
going to attract a higher
higher higher bar a higher average level
because we are a higher paying
organization and
you know there's a bunch of economic
theory behind that and their belief is
that they're going to attract better
talent and you know what they end up
with
the exact same problems as all other
organizations they still have a bell
curve they still have underperformers
and this is something you said too is
even in the sealed teams and people
create this image on their mind of
what a seal is and they're you know
they're superhuman and how many times
have you said
no they're people the exact same thing
at top gun where people place these guys
on a pedestal as if they're
somehow all of them uniquely capable and
we had a bottom
12 at top gun too we had
underperformers at top gun just like
everywhere else so
for me to think about it if you're in a
leadership role
the takeaway from this is that what is
required for all this is your leadership
more than anything now i'll i do want to
hear his thoughts on that but
your underperformance can still undo
your plan and there's no like free pass
of hey we just have a better screening
process so we don't we weed out those
people well
we know that that's not true those
problems exist in the same bell curve in
any every organization
yeah and the other thing that affects
the bell curve is
the bar that everyone has to
be staying above so the bottom 12
percent
at top gun they're the bottom 12 top gun
they may be the top tier of some other
organization somewhere
but at top gun they're the bottom 12 and
and they're making the same
kind of mistakes relative
to their job it's the same thing the
seal team's like oh yeah
the the seal teams they have a we have a
bottom part of the bell curve
now those people might be really good if
they had some other job somewhere
you know in task unit bruiser we we had
to get rid of one guy he was a great guy
he was a hard worker he just didn't
quite
have the capacity to get the job done i
guarantee he went to his next
unit in the navy and was the best sailor
they had i i can i can
i can guarantee that because he was a
hard worker
he wanted to do a good job he just
didn't quite have that decision-making
process
and maybe i shouldn't have said the best
sailor but he's going to be a really
good guy
a really good guy and and so but the bar
yeah is is is higher for what you're
being required to do
right this is what you're like a top gun
you're being required to fly this
jet at these at these g's and make these
decisions and maneuver and
remember what's happening and debrief
and communicate and and pay attention to
nine different things at the same time
you're required to do all that stuff
and the the people that are barely able
to do it they're the bottom of the bell
curve
you put them you know driving an uber
and they're going to be the best
freaking uber driver you know in
well at least in the top let's say the
top five percent of uber driver because
i've had some damn good uber drivers
before
so so yes that that bell curve exists
everywhere you're not going to get away
from it and you do
have to lead and i and i agree with your
point
why general clark might be saying hey
you got to pay attention
to that bottom 12 because
no one in the top 88
is gonna well there's a much less
there's much less chance of them
torpedoing your whole mission right
those knuckleheads they they're holding
the freaking trigger to the torpedo and
they could fire that thing off at any
moment so you got to pay attention to
them
that might be the the the genesis of his
of his focus on these individuals
is that probably where the what's the
saying you're only as strong as your
weakest link kind of a
philosophy right yep yeah maybe that's
where it came from
it's it's from that definitely from that
concept
that broad concept
he goes on here single squad crew or
section will probably contain men of all
three groupings
certainly they will appear in any
platoon or company this presents a
practical problem in the handling and
instructing of men
in perfecting the teamwork of the squad
crew secondary platoon
the leader can afford to adopt only one
approach to handling his men
he must assume that they all want to do
what he wants done when any number do
not respond to this assumption
the fault is more probably his than
theirs
so his assumption is everyone's that's a
great assumption to make the assumption
and that's what i like about this
assumption that all men want to do what
what has
wanted them to do what we want them to
do that's a great assumption to make
because that means when they don't it's
our fault and that's exactly what he's
saying he's taking full ownership
and then he says this is like almost
word for word for something that i brief
almost on a daily basis companies
if they don't respond he should check
his procedures
instructions and subordinate leaders to
determine where in lies the trouble
when only one or two individuals are
involved punitive action or elimination
may be indicated so if you've got a
platoon or a company got a company of
150 people and everyone gets it except
for two guys
okay well maybe i need to check those
two guys and maybe i need to get rid of
them but
if you've got whatever 20 people that
don't understand what they're supposed
to be doing guess what it's on you
we arrive now at the fourth precept
the best unit in the organization is
always the one which is excellent or
better in all things
which is based upon the premise that no
unit commander has enough time to make
his unit superior in
all things at all times how therefore
should he spread his efforts it's
obvious that his unit must be proficient
in marksmanship communication supply
administration tactics physical fitness
techniques maintenance etc
etc etc if his unit is not
proficient in any one of these things
his team is not sound and will fail him
when the test comes how then must he
manage
so he got all these things and you
obviously can't be and he's
he's making a difference or or making a
um a break between
superior which means you're awesome at
this thing
and being good at it
first he should avoid putting too much
stress on any one thing
so as to over emphasize it in order to
make a show of it
if he practices this method he will do
do so at the expense of other important
things this is a common error
so you're not you shouldn't be the
master of anything you should be the
jack of all trades
second he must stress adequately all of
the many facets of the training
job even though he is not an expert in
each he must
direct a subordinate to be an expert and
the commander must then
supervise and check his subordinates
work the latter
is important so you're not going to be
an expert as the leader knocking the
expert you got some
you got some nugs under you that are
gonna be the expert in that thing
next section's called motivation woven
into the entire pattern are the threads
of motivation this motivation is
manifestly important because it comes
from a spree enthusiasm morale effort
competition and accomplishment
the people in each of the top middle and
lower groupings need to be motivated in
different ways and in varying degrees
which is a little different than when he
said earlier says the leader can only
afford to adopt one approach when
handling his men
little little dichotomy
you got different people they're gonna
get motivated in different ways
in encouraging students to learn we
motivate them by one or more of the
following
one show a need to develop an interest
both those are explaining why right this
is why this is important that's what the
need is
here's how you get someone to develop an
interest in something you explain to
them how it's going to help them
maintain the interest that's also
explaining why and then he's got some
other things encouraging early success
giving recognition and credit using
competition giving rewards awarding
punishments
these same things may be used to incite
a body of men or military unit into
action
undoubtedly every commander sometime
during his career after being assigned a
difficult task
has soon soon thereafter considered how
he would present this task to his
subordinates
how he would appeal them to get the job
done in short on
what he would base his efforts to
motivate them
to tackle the job with the will
necessary to attain
the goal sought he will probably use
many factors to motivate his unit some
of them may be specifically mentioned
and some may be implied
for instance except as a last resort
he would not mention punishment in this
case of failure his men would know him
well enough to know that he would not
stand for failure
the real art in motivating a group of
men to accomplish a common mission is to
reach each man
in such a way that all men in the unit
are incited to the extent of their
several capabilities of course the kind
of mission to be performed by the men
will be will determine the motivating
factors used
but there is one element that must be
kept in mind and that
is that no amount of motivation will
incite a man
to undertake zealously that which he
knows
is manifestly beyond his capabilities
so big chunk about motivation there and
you know i
i was talking i can't remember as a
client or if it was ef online the other
day
um but you know when you get told the
the the proverbial you know you get
tasked with something that doesn't make
any sense
and the boss just says yo shut up and
have your team do it and then what do
you do how do you
how do you handle that what do you say
to the troops and and
i'm like i will find a reason why all
day long that is awesome
you know i will go and i'm not gonna lie
to him i'm gonna say hey listen
boss just told us this is how we're
doing it and you know what we're gonna
do we're gonna knock this thing out of
the park
that way i'm gonna build some trust with
a boss he's gonna realize that we can
get the job done when he realized that
we can get the job done he's gonna start
to listen to me once he starts listening
to me
i'm gonna get this changed so right now
we're gonna crush this thing
and the guys go yes or i'm gonna say hey
look no one else is able to do this
we're the only
people that can get this done the boss
knows it we know it so we're gonna knock
this thing out of the park
like i'm gonna figure out a reason
there's got to be a reason why
that makes sense to do this thing and
believe me if i can't find a reason
we're getting told to do something that
makes
no sense whatsoever is gonna get people
unnecessarily wounded or killed
or it's unethical or it's immoral or
it's illegal that's what's going on
otherwise i can figure out a reason and
i'm talking about a good i'm not talking
about making something up to trick
people i'm talking about i will figure
out
a good freaking reason to go forward and
make this happen
and that's what you need to do as a boss
that's that's why the why is so
important
talks about awards
in the army we use freely a system of
awards and prizes in order to motivate
men too often these go to the men in the
top of the upper group
they provide no incentive for
improvement to those
in the lower group and little for those
in the middle group because the men
know that the award is beyond their
ability to achieve these prizes make
good articles for the unit papers
but their overall effect on the unit is
negligible
it is well to recognize the outstanding
men
and we do this through proficiency pay
and promotion
however our system awards must
go beyond this recognition of
individuals this is a great point you
know
so often we're sitting there rewarding
the people that are kind of doing well
who
actually probably don't need any
additional motivation look should we
recognize them absolutely
but what are we doing for the the middle
group and even the lower group to make
sure that they're
feeling like they're moving forward in a
positive way yeah
you know when you're like in elementary
school and you have like the award for
most
improved that's like kind of alleviates
that issue right a little bit
because usually it's like someone in the
middle maybe even the bottom a lot of
the times when you still get that cool
like
trophy or yeah whatever because you
improved so much
is that a little backhanded smack though
i guess you can rack up the most
improved
i've gotten it before yes no i don't
think it is though i don't think it is a
backhanded thing because it's true like
you know when you get like um
uh you know mvp of the football game
it's always the same guy
the quarterback whatever the guy you
know obviously depends on the team but
it's that guy that's he's already
training by the way and he's already
talented and gifted and he's working
hard and he's focused
yeah and the ward the guys in the middle
you do run that risk big time where it's
like guys in the middle i was like oh
yeah well
i i don't even have an expectation of
the award
you know but if you get if you get most
improved
bro you can get most improved that's
good you know especially if everyone
respects it because everyone typically
does respect that if you're
improving i had uh there's something
called the navy achievement medal did
you ever get navy achievement metal
so navy achievement metal is like you
know it's it's sort of like
it's a it's a strong pat on the back
we'll say and you know
you might get one when something happens
you know you're a young enlisted guy
i think i had six navy achievement
medals which is totally ridiculous i
would get those things all the time
for like what's it for though like oh i
would run a communications course when i
these are all from the 90s it'd be like
you know petty officer willing ran an
outstanding you know
communications course he organized lead
and developed the blah blah blah
stoner used to like laugh every time i
put my my dress uniform on because i had
five navy achievement medals like the
big rack
of stars across my navy across my names
get some yeah but i feel like i
know but i feel like i was kind of that
guy like i was working hard
and they were just giving me awards and
i was like cool whatever i don't care
i didn't care at all yeah i wasn't like
hey
check out my names well then okay then
i guess if you kind of go into it i mean
in all kinds of environments right
there's all kinds of different awards
like that that are
that are you can get without being the
top like producer or whatever like you
got
okay you got most improved then you got
like hardest worker or something like
that
you know you know do you ever get that
one no okay that's not to say
as far as like expectations of metal
that was that was one i never really
expected
but the but you get those how many nams
do you have dave
one what did you get a damn thing i got
an end of tournament
damn so was this when you were like an
ensign or uh
first first tour in a squadron so as
you're thinking i was
uh i'm laughing because you know when
you're talking about even the way you're
saying ma'am like anybody in the navy in
the marine corps
knows like the namm is like this thing
this navy achievement medal is
like and i racked up five of those bro
but you know something that's something
that's actually cool that you said
is there's a couple different ways to
view like the award system in the
military
it can be a little questionable there's
people who can kind of peel that back
and go man is that is that legit or not
we had two different categories of the
same award we had what we called an
endotour award which went okay
you know petty officer willing has been
with us for three years he's leaving the
squad or the unit or whatever and he's
going we want to recognize his body of
work
it's kind of like a participation award
it doesn't have a ton of meaning other
than
you survived your three years we want to
thank you on your way out
there was something else we called was
an impact name or we had a term called a
strive by
nam oh we call them a spot thing
it's called now spot just the same it's
the same thing i was racking up which
means like i was going out of style
there's no way to make this this make
this serious there's five names
but the point behind that is like you
can take a middle of the road dude
middle road guy who's who's not your
all-star quarterback
not your top tier guy and he's over
there doing some good work
yes so maybe that was me dude yeah maybe
i don't know they were trying to
five is a bit ridiculous um i don't have
five of
anything but there is a way to
when you when you recognize somebody for
their work
it's a heck of a lot better to recognize
them for something they're doing when we
call the impact or the spot as opposed
to
well you've been with us for five years
you get a watch like that's our thing
so here's your here's your you've been
here for five years as opposed to
hey that thing you did that specific
thing if you could recognize people for
that
in this leadership little system you're
trying to create is
it's really good to recognize people for
the work that they do when they do it as
opposed to
well we just sort of have this process
that by these wickets or these little
checkpoints you get
recognition which over time sort of
undermines the value of it
and and again five's a well
that's a lot dude but the nam is not a i
mean you're talking about straight up
essentially
a participation trophy like you oh
you've been here five years my
anticipated was a participation award
i was leaving captain's got nams
i don't care if you were the number one
captain or the number 12 captain when
you left
you got an am and and the number one
guy didn't go well i actually earned
this one and the number 12 guy didn't
think well this is garbage
it had no real meaning the the impact
would you call it a
spot the spot it was called the spot
that's a that's there's a lot more
legitimacy to that than hey thanks for
being here
dude yeah you gotta look on your face
bro like you're all fired up from my
name
here's the thing but that's a perfect
point right there because if they're
if a spot nam and a regular
participation trophy nam is the same
sort of thing then it's like oh wait you
got to differentiate those two because
if you're over you're saying you got
five there is a differentiation on the
nam that is you can get a v
which is when it becomes a combat award
so a namm with a combat v
or a uh combat distinguishing
device is what they call it so it has a
v on it and that's
that's a legit award and i a lot of guys
in task and a bruiser got
nams with these and those names with
these that
the guys got into asking a bruiser were
hard-earned they weren't like oh you're
just gonna
you you there was some gunfire near but
no like these guys were
in 18 firefights and they got a nam with
a v
yeah and and you know the some of the
guys in in task unit bruiser
some of stoners guys they got the r com
which the army combination metal with a
v that was a huge deal because those
things are
tough to get the marine corps does not
give out those things and that came from
the uh from the army recognizing what
you were doing which which added that
which added to that as well yeah there's
a couple things in the military have a
little bit of sanctity the
v yeah whether it's a nam a com whatever
it is
the v that has there there's me
you can't just get a v you got to earn
that combat distinguishing device
the other one in the marine corps that
shouldn't say the marine corps navy and
the marine corps
is what we call the car the combat
action ribbon they don't like to just
you don't just
that's not a participation award you you
got to earn that car yeah and the cib in
the army
which is the exact combat influence
which means you
you've been in combat yeah and that's
that's what that's what hackworth
called out uh the admiral for admiral
borda
for wearing a combat v on his nam
it was actually an i think it was it was
a nam with a v on it
and he and hackworth said this guy was
in vietnam but he wasn't he was on a
ship he wasn't in direct combat with the
and admiral border killed himself yeah
over this
drama over a it's crazy now that i'm you
know we're sitting here laughing you're
like oh this we can't ever get serious
again all we have to do is talk about
admiral borda
and and and colonel hackworth calling
him out for wearing a combat v
and he kills himself in the navy yard
to your five nams no
if some of those were like for some
solid work you did on this little thing
that you thought maybe wasn't that huge
of a deal but you did some good work and
people
saw what you did and you're like hey hey
look you didn't save the world but you
did really good with that little
whatever you did that's different than a
participation trophy type situation
all fired up i was stoked you know i was
trying to work hard trying to do a good
job and people were giving me cool
recognition
and i appreciated it i'm just saying
when you fast forward it
from 1995 to like
2009 and we're back from ramadi
and i'm putting my dress uniform on and
stoner sees me and he's and we're
laughing because i have
five nams which is really really it's
also especially ridiculous i was an
officer and it's like an officer's if
you're an officer he got fi
i mean dave burke you know who is in the
marine corps for 24 years had
one nam and there i was walking around
with five that's kind of it just there's
something funny about it
yeah it is so to the officers
and chiefs that gave me recognition as a
young enlisted guy i appreciate it
uh it meant a lot to me but over time it
did become a little bit funny and a
little bit ridiculous that i was walking
around with five nams i'm gonna have to
now post a picture
i don't think i have any of this stuff
anymore but i realize that i'm
probably coming off as nam obsessed at
this point you are a little bit but
or should i say end i'm going to write
you up for once i just so you ever got
employee of the month
at you know you i was in the military my
whole life brad never no you worked at
wendy's
oh yeah i was never employed okay but
isn't that the same thing
employee of the month
i would rather get a name than employee
of the month at wendy's but it's the
same thing
it's just not in the military i'm saying
it's a similar thing
namms were harder to get than employee
of the month there was no guarantee that
name was being issued
right it's going to be a guy they got to
choose somebody but still same deal as
far as like the structure
you seem saying where it's like you're
getting awarded for something you did
even though in your mind it might not be
that big of a deal
but as an individual like process it's
kind of a
thing it's something it's just not
nothing you see we'll go with it
we'll go with it
all right back to the book summary and
conclusion the job of those of us who
are privileged to command to create
superior units from the run of the r
from the ordinary run of manpower made
available to us
this manpower falls into upper middle
and lower groups
about equal in strength that have
different capabilities present different
problems
and need to be handled differently all
of the men in a unit must be assumed to
desire to do what is wanted
and when they do not they have not been
properly handled and instructed and i
would add the word
lead there the best and most reliable
unit
is usually the one that is excellent in
all things
even though it might not be superior in
any way
so that's the difference he he breaks
out the
hierarchy of adjectives the highest
adjective being superior and then
below that is excellent and excellent is
better to be excellent at everything
than superior
one thing throughout the whole job runs
the problem of motivation this problem
is
not solved unless steps are made to
motivate the unit carefully thought out
and applied in such a way that their
effect is felt by all men in the unit
finally excellence of the unit is
measured by the extent to which
those of the lower third of the unit are
developed to play their part
of the unit team you know still not 100
on board with that one
as far as i'm concerned motivation is
about understanding why you're doing
what you're doing
and giving people ownership you want to
motivate people tell them why they're
doing what they're doing and let them
take ownership of it and run with it
i feel like motivation um is like
kind of oh there's like short term and
long term and you know like um
i was thinking of something very
specific at the time where
you know people get mad when they get
angry at something it motivates them
like
super hardcore but only short term and
then if somebody someone's the opposite
if someone's really happy or i don't
know thankful or whatever
that like keeps them sort of motivated
long term that's good i i would agree
with that
unless they have like some sort of weird
underlying fear of something that might
you know sustain them long term i don't
know yeah you could get into some
details but i think a broad statement
that
like some kind of an anger would be a
short more of a short-term motivation
and a uh uh
happiness a satisfaction a gratification
would be more of a long term i would i
would agree with that
i would tend to agree with that all
right now we're going to get into um
man i thought those were kind of like
hey we'll just burn through some of
those chapters i'm sorry
because i wanted to get to this chapter
which is called chapter 13 mission type
orders the problem of control
in world war ii those who served in
armored divisions and probably in other
units as well
learned that mission type orders were a
requirement if the most was to be
obtained from a command
since then we have hat and mission type
so what mission types orders are
just in a nutshell is you tell somebody
what needs to happen you let them go
figure out how to do it
it's very it's these it's the it's the
basis of decentralized command
since then we've had to con consider the
control of operations in the fluidity
and unpredictability of nuclear battle
as battle becomes more complex and
unpredictable responsibilities
must be more and more decentralized
thus mission type orders often will be
used at all
echelons of command and probably will be
the rule
at the division and higher levels this
will require
all commanders to exercise initiative
resourcefulness
and imagination operating with relative
freedom of action and this is what's
weird you know he he oscillates between
these sort of like
everyone should be you know how do we
control the men and he literally says in
that earlier chapter the the
middle group is easier to control and
now he's saying hey you need to let them
go and operate
and it's really scary i thought he was
going to start talking about nuclear war
what do you
when you think about nuclear war i think
centralized control
i want 17 people to make sure that that
is the right move
before that freaking fire button gets
hit and those two keys get
simultaneously turned
but he's like no decentralized command
that's pretty scary to me um in our
tactical
in our tactical forces we have built-in
organizational flexibility we must
recognize this and capitalize it
in our orders to get maximum combat
power
we must have plans flexible enough to
meet rapidly changing situations
but careful planning is not enough this
must be coupled with the readiness to
change and adapt to situations
as they are not as they are expected to
be
awesome what's interesting about that is
he says we need to make
uh plans flexible enough to meet rapidly
changing
situations and he says but careful
planning is not enough when i think of
careful planning i think oh this guy's
gonna sit there and plan every detail i
don't think of
somebody that's thinking hey we're going
to come up with a very flexible plan
a flexible plan to me is not careful
planning
i i guess i might be reading too much
into that
but i always felt like i cheated all the
time because i came up with flexible
plans for things yeah
yeah it seems like a carefully plan
or a plan plan carefully is like you
care you
carefully plan for like contingencies
yeah i guess carefully plan doesn't
necessarily mean to be
doesn't need to be overly detailed in
fact carefully planned could be like hey
we want to be careful that we don't put
too much detail in here
and then yes being able to adapt to
situations as they are
not as they were expected to be that's a
critical way to operate
to train commanders and staff officers
for operations in war where mission type
orders will be widely used it is
necessary that tactical courses in our
schools
teach the use of such orders and that we
widely
employ mission type orders in our
peacetime operations
i love that so when you're going to give
people assignments to clean up the
building
you don't say you mop and you scrub and
you clean and you go no you say hell
with building clean
this is what time it needs to be done by
and you let them go execute it
boom decentralized command mission type
order
and and think about that
i just kind of blew that off but that's
a real thing like if you don't
train people and you don't live like
this
then you won't get good at it you have
to actually live like this
this has to be your way of life
if the way that you run your day-to-day
operations is micromanagement
how can you expect anybody to do
anything other than be micromanaged when
you get into a bad situation and get in
a combat situation
you said something really solid on ef
online
that i was exposed to when you're like
hey when you're in a meeting
or you're having a meeting or something
and everyone's there with their pen
and paper waiting for you to say
something to write stuff down and then
when you start talking then they start
writing
stuff down or whatever it's a bad sign
yeah it's a bad time but it even but it
feels good it feels good
no one can do anything unless big jump
rolls in yeah
man with the big ego and the plan you're
really a horrible leader if they're all
sitting there waiting
yeah we got two or three questions we
already know what we're doing we know
where we're going
yeah we're good
oh this is beautiful
scope of a mission type order basically
a mission
type order needs to cover only three
important things
one it should clearly state what the
commandee what the commander issuing the
order
wants to have accomplished that's number
one this is what this is what you need
to accomplish
number two it should point out the
limiting or control factors that must be
observed
for coordinating factors so
okay you can't go across this area you
can't fly over this region
you you can't enter into this zone
here's the limitations
and then finally it should delineate the
resources made available to the
subordinate commander
and the support which he can expect or
count on
from sources outside of his command
that's all you need to know
tell me what to do tell me what the
limitations are and tell me what
resources i have
other than that leave me alone i'm gonna
go make it happen
that's that's that might be the clearest
definition of a mission type order i've
ever read in my life that's all you need
i got asked one time i was in my first
deployment to
iraq and my boss is like what
information do you need
and how much time do you need to launch
on a mission and i was like
i need to know what where the location
of the target
the frequencies of the friendly forces
and i need 15 minutes and we'll go
yes um
confidence in subordinate commanders
there is a strong reluctance at every
headquarters to relinquish the
authority to direct the details of an
operation
this reluctance is clearly seen in the
embellishments added to an
order as it threads its way down the
company level careful judgment must be
made at every echelon of command
in stating the limiting and controlling
factors of a mission type order
confidence must be placed in judgment
and ability of the subordinate commander
too often what starts off as a broad
mission type order at the high echelon
ends up with
of my new detailed and restricting
instructions specifying
how to get the job done when it finally
gets down to company level
many officers hearing this may think
they would like to have a command
functioning under such a
system meaning i would love it if people
would just do exactly what i told them
to do but you don't want that
others who may say they would like to
work under such a system really are
disturbed by thoughts of it
there are some officers who require
something in writing
before they will take significant action
a mission type order requires the
subordinate commander and his staff to
make basic decisions and plans based
upon
a careful analysis of the situation if
the basic decisions or plans are not
successful there is no paper foxhole
into which they can crawl mission type
orders require
initiative promptness and
resourcefulness
which are not always forthcoming
problems in service schools
based upon such orders bring forth a
variety of solutions
which are difficult for the faculty to
grade sometimes
looms as a very important problem
what do you got dude that
there is so much there you even gave
this example of just
cleaning the building just that little
example of cleaning the building
the worst thing i can do as a leader
is to tell you how to do that because
the minute i tell you how
you know what you're going to do exactly
what i told you and i'm going to say
this this this and this
what are the chances i get it all as a
leader
yeah zero right so what you're actually
going to do is what i told you to do
but i'm going to miss couple things and
actually the outcome is not gonna be
what i want and
then i usually don't go and inspect him
like hey you can do this need to do that
and what happens is i trust you less
someone might remind you even more which
means you have even less initiative the
next time
and the connection from how to
initiative and what i wrote down was
how by me telling you how to do what i
want you to do
and i'm not saying like teaching you how
to do something i'm telling you how i
want it done
that's the how you're talking about of
course i want to teach you how to do a
task or a job i need to train you
he's talking about i want this is how i
want you to do this task
which is totally different that is the
exact opposite
of initiative because if i tell you how
to do it you're going to do exactly
how i told you to do it and then the
things that i've missed the things that
as a commander don't know because i'm
farther away from the problem than you
are
i'm gonna trust you less because the
outcome is gonna be the wrong one i'm
gonna micromanage more i'm gonna
undermine your initiative even more and
then when you're out there doing it on
your own and i actually can't get to you
which is the connection from the
training to the real world which is why
i have to live this all the time
that's when teams and organizations fail
because i'm not going to be there to
solve all these problems for you but
i've bred this in you the entire time
because i'm always telling you how i
want you to do it and you're like cool
i'll do exactly how you told me to do it
and i'm not going to do this i'm not
going to do that you don't even know
about this over here i'm just not even
touching that because you didn't tell me
about that at all
but if you go the exact opposite which
was hey
however you want to get this done that's
all good what we need to get it done is
by 1600 on wednesday because what
happens at 1700 on wednesday is this
this and this it impacts all that
go make it happen all of that is your
initiative to go make that happen
just the connection between me telling
you how i want it done versus your
initiative and the and the inner
the inverse relationship between those
two and how often we see that done wrong
bra that's so true like every your drive
with a
micro manager like direction giver you
know
like you know driving with you you're
just like whatever takes us here
whatever kind of thing
and that's a good move even if i make
wrong turns whatever you know you'll
help
occasionally you know and you'll help
whatever but you get in
you ever drive with somebody who's like
hey don't be in this lane this lane is
like too
slow or whatever and it's like okay make
this turn it's got you know like
a micro manager what do you call them
well front seat drive backseat driver or
whatever
that kind of person yeah let's say it's
your significant other i'm not saying
it's my significant other i'm not sure
for a friend but
it's not hypothetically hypothetically
yes someone who you drive with a lot is
what i'm saying
so and every time it's like hey you know
we're going to go this route hey get out
of this lane go in this lane okay take
this turn you know okay
it's coming right you know like really
kind of micromanaging your driving uh
situation after a while you start you
kind of get used to that
yeah and now and now all of a sudden
you're not paying attention they go wait
a second you're supposed to take that
turn you're like
why didn't you tell me yeah it's a weird
subconscious why don't you tell me sarah
charles
it's a subconscious almost dependence
for sure totally that's exactly
100 what it is yeah 100 that's the
initiative comment that i'm that
connected to is like i got i'm going to
take no initiative because i'm you've
been
trained to just wait to be told what to
do
exactly right so just like how you're
saying where
now if let's say i'm dependent on you to
give me directions
you don't you know the leader whatever
he doesn't always get it right or
whatever i make the wrong
call or you don't give me direction
we'll say you don't give me direction i
take no action
and then of course it's done wrong now
you trust me less
and now and around and around we go you
know so
yeah and i micromanage you more and i
stifle even more of your initiative
even more exactly right you know what's
crazy about this and
davey and i were talking about this
before we pressed record
he's like i basically think in
commander's intent
like i i think the way my mind works i
think in end states
and i and everything else to me is just
sort of this
almost like an annoyance of reality and
i'm so
far like when i want to do something i'm
so
there that everything else is just sort
of going to fall into place and i'm not
even thinking about it
you know whether it's like when i'm
starting to write a book like i know
what
i know what that book is i know the
insight and what it looks like and now i
just have to
get those words out of my system when
we're gonna launch something
it's like i already know what's gonna
happen even
if you think about something as stupid
as this podcast
of me being like echo can you make a
podcast and you're like well let me go
figure it out you figured out i'm like i
don't even
care nothing i'd care zero you show up
with what you could have shown up with
with a freaking a tape recorder and i
would have been like okay is that what
we're doing
sounds good all right we're good because
i know what i know where this is going
to go
i know where we're going and so where
however we're going to get there it's
like an annoyance to me
and it's an it's the annoyance of
reality yeah
because of where my mind is what i'm
thinking about where we're going
and that's that's a positive thing for a
couple reasons
number one if you're working for me if
you're making stuff happen
you're good to go i mean you you can
just you make stuff happen but we're
good
we're good we're totally good i'm never
gonna bother you
never gonna bother you so that's rad and
then also
the the
i'm not getting caught up in these
details which means that step that i
take is going to be a big one
it's going to be a big step it's not
going to be a little i'm not going to
take half measures
yeah we're going the distance so i'm
thinking and
acting and kind of living in like a
commander's intent kind of way
yeah it's not kinda
for those of us that are inside that
sphere the byproduct of you is a leader
thinking in outcomes and end states if
that's how you're thinking and and
leading your people
the natural reaction of the people
around you is to fill in all those
things
to make sure that happens and if you can
take it a step further
if you can take it a step further as a
leader and
also be comfortable with the other side
of it which is a phrase that you use all
the time which i love which is
you gotta expect those things to happen
then it's no factor if
exactly how you had this picture in your
mind you got a little detour a little
roadblock little problem here yeah those
things are going to happen
and we and we can solve those things too
using the exact same approach which is
if you have that attitude as a leader
when your people run into problems
they're not going to be panic stricken
about what is the boss going to think
because he's gonna say hey look i expect
those things happen those things are
gonna happen and i'm gonna end up
solving that
as well and so if you can connect the
idea of thinking in end states around
your people and also letting your people
know
you're not gonna fly off the handle and
jump right in there start to micromanage
them when get these little hiccups these
little
deviations because you actually in your
mind jocko haven't thought about
all the things that happen between here
and here you don't really care what's
going on in here
cool you go off that cool i expect those
things to happen
but the minute you lay that all out like
all these 30 steps to get there and one
doesn't go right and then you're
involved in that
what that does to stifle your people
makes it so much harder for them to get
to your end state so
just combine the two of thinking in
those end states
and then letting your people solve those
things along the way and not
overreacting to the
problems that occur as you're getting
there because things are messy those
little things are messy but by the way
if you're thinking about all those
things in between
you don't even you you're not even going
to think about a bigger picture
you're going to be thinking like hey we
need to move to this next ridgeline
you're not thinking about
where you're going to end up in two days
on this operation or we're going to end
up strategically in three months you're
like
you're not even thinking about that
you're thinking about wait a second
there's an obstacle right in front of us
what are we gonna do
totally and meanwhile i'm like i don't
care i literally don't care there's 19
different ways to solve that problem
pick one of them and roll with it
and oh you owe you oh it didn't work and
you got to try again cool whatever i'm
still over here and guess where i'm
looking off in the distance so we're
good
that's a good point and and maybe
i don't know maybe in my experience
which is nothing but in my experience
is um like under appreciated or whatever
like not flying off the handle when
things go
wrong like if you
like you know you're like hey but it's
true though like yeah
you know you people have this
misconception that you like oh what if
dracula gets mad at you for making this
or doing that
the reality is you don't really get mad
at mistakes
you know like you might tease me a
little bit of whatever but
yeah like you don't get mad that but
what that does is and when i was
listening to you dave
say that and stuff it it made me
remember yeah that's true like i don't
have a fear of making the wrong move
if we both know where we're sort of
going you know and guess what that means
you can move
exactly that means you can you can make
two three four seven
moves you can make seven moves
and you never had to talk to me and six
of them were right nine of them were
right
11 out of 12 were right there was one
wrong one it set you back
a half a move and then you pressed
forward and it was no factor
if if i was concerned that jacob was
going to get mad at me for
i don't know what if i make the wrong
decision on this like should we do this
or should i do this or should i not
do this or whatever but i'd be like you
wouldn't be making decisions
it would work way worse yeah somebody
quoted you on twitter it was like
a great way to not waste your people's
time is to not
make the every not make sure that you're
the one that's making all the decisions
for
not make them reliant on you to make
those decisions that's a great way to
not waste their time yes
and the beauty of that is that they're
gonna get you to where you want to go
faster for sure i think you're right
about that for sure
all right so this is how they close out
the section this is once again this is
such a
there's a dichotomy with general clark
and this is part of that
dichotomy right now and he's talked
about it before
the channel of suggestion
i have said many times that a commander
has two channels within which to operate
he has the channel of command barking
orders
and the channel of suggestion i believe
that a good commander who has
subordinates who are trained and have
the confidence to use mission type
orders
can operate almost exclusively
using the channel of suggestion
reserving the channel of command
for for use only when he wants to give
special emphasis to an order
to relieve someone or to take
disciplinary
action that's the only time he's talking
other than that it's like well how do
you want to do it what do you think we
should do the only time he's going to
bark orders is when he's going to fire
someone
which is what relieve means by the way
in in the military relieve someone means
you're firing them
or to give disciplinary actions
every other time almost exclusively it's
channel of suggestion
you just made the leap by saying it it
was in my head as when when i'm hearing
suggestion i'm not even hearing
suggestion i'm hearing
questions hey what do you think how do
you think which isn't even what is that
and saying in word because suggested
means like hey what maybe we should do
this
you're taking it a step further which is
how do you think we should do this
and then the flip side too is that the
hammer of real you know as a commander
you have that hammer
you can drop that hammer i can fire
somebody i can relieve somebody i could
reduce their rank
i could take their pay there was a lot
of authority in command
how often do you want to pull out that
hammer man
the more you know well you just pulled
out the big the big hammer
right what about the little hammer eve
the little hammer is even worse
the little hammer of like actually dave
we need to do it this way smack a little
you know actually dave i don't like your
idea smack and meanwhile you're
getting all dinged up and now you don't
want to make any moves anymore
the suggest suggestion is is actually
question
how should we do this yeah channel of
suggestion
uh here's the final little section and
this is i i briefed you earlier dave i
said there's gonna be something i'm
gonna read that you're gonna say yes
so this is that section further
the mission of the higher headquarters i
went to leavenworth
and people think leavenworth they think
of going to prison because there is a
military prison there but there's also
the war college
i went to leavenworth over 20 years ago
so it was difficult for me to remember
all the things which i must have learned
then at the command and general staff
college the one thing that i have never
forgotten
and which has stood me in good stead
was the teaching of general mcnair then
commandant when he stated
quote when you receive an order
or a directive from your next higher
commander
do everything you can and in the best
way you can
to further the mission which he wants to
accomplish
end quote an officer who follows his
advice
and uses it to interpret his
instructions we'll find that he can act
wisely promptly and aggressively with
confidence he will have no problem in
operating in in an environment with
mission type orders
so when your boss tells you to do
something
freaking do it and do it to the best of
your ability
uh leadership strategy and tactics i
always have to go to this page
but uh it's it's it's the the things
that says how to succeed is a new
leader page 157 and then on page 158
it says lastly get the job done get the
job done
that's what you're supposed to do and
that's what he's talking about when you
get told to do something
do it people talk to me how do i build a
good relationship with my boss do the
job and do it well
kick ass give your boss credit you'll
start building a good relationship with
them
chapter 14 organization for performing
tasks on the company at small unit level
the purpose of this chapter set forth
the concept of which i've found from
experience improves training
uses time devoted to training more
efficiently and increases responsibility
prestige
and morale of the non-commissioned
officer leader and platoon leader
organizational user organizational units
or teams
even for work details and i'm not going
to read this section but
what he says we're using this example
today of
cleaning the building what he's saying
is when you killing the building do it
as a platoon yeah
so use mission type orders and then do
it as a platoon
and and that just helps them get used to
how operating together what people are
like what it's like for that leader
when that leader what what how that
leader relates to the to the troops how
the troops relate back to the leader
you train how you operate you work how
you train
and then there's the last section in
this part is let the leader lead his men
which is the same thing
under the detailed procedure of
performing necessary unit tasks all
training teams are represented
at all scheduled training this may make
a good showing
in their training accomplish records but
does not necessarily mean that they have
actually received as teams the training
that is shown on record
however maintaining unit integrity
while performing daily tasks will also
enhance
real benefits which we derive from our
team training so every day
you should live you should operate the
way
you are going to live and operate
chapter 15 wasting soldiers time the
value of time we americans have always
been conscious of the value of time
benjamin franklin expressed this by
saying that time is money
in our country the efficiency expert who
comes in to examine ways of doing things
to eliminate wasted motion
is highly paid for his services he
commands that high price
because he is a saver of time
in the army we speak of resources in
terms of the three m's
men money and materials to these three
we must add time however there is a
distinct difference between time and the
other three resources
if we do not use our money or materials
today they are available tomorrow
to a lesser degree this is also true of
men it is not
at all true of time for the time for
time is a highly perishable
commodity and our loss today is lost
forever
echo charles it's true i feel like
he's training a lot of soldiers today
it cost several thousand dollars a year
to maintain each soldier in the army i
consider that is probably a cost of five
dollars per hour per man for the
soldier's training time
that is available to the company
commander thus when the commander wastes
an
hour of his company's time he may be
wasting as much as a thousand dollars
we would not want to be embarrassed if
some agency became interested in
investigating this in the field
that's an interesting way to think about
think about you know companies 150
men but think about your company think
about your business think about your
team
you got people sitting and
you weren't prepared for the meeting or
the meeting starts late or whatever
whatever it is you think about what
you're throwing away you're wasting
people's
time we are engaged in a contest
with the communists in which there is no
civil matter
in which no silver medal will be awarded
for second place
i'm certain that it is unnecessary for
me to dwell on the importance of the
role the us army in this contest
our mission is to be combat ready to my
way of thinking
combat readiness has no upper
limit a unit is
never 100 combat ready because there is
always room for improvement in the
development of military skills reaction
time
marksmanship and the like combat
readiness is a
goal toward which we are constantly
moving but which we should never feel we
have wholly achieved
our progress will depend on our use of
the resources which i
mentioned previously i want to stress
the importance of using
time wisely
and then he goes through a bunch of you
know how we waste time
time is wasted in administration and
paperwork
and red tape and
he says this you should consider it
unforgivable
you should consider it unforgivable to
remove a man from a scheduled formal
period
of instruction or practical work to take
care of administrative matters
you cannot requisition a replacement for
a lost hour of training
he also says here we waste time when we
over commit our units
or perhaps i should say we do not make
the best use of our time
that's something we got to pay attention
to on an individual level
you over schedule yourself and you
actually end up wasting time
the same wastage is presented on the
individual level when the strength of a
unit is filtered away to participate in
contests of non-military skills
to paint rocks or plant flower beds in a
likeness of the unit's insignia
that's a shot right there you go around
military paces in america there's some
painted rocks out there people there's
some white painted rocks that are lined
in some roads
and i'm gonna tell you some privates
painted those rocks
they probably got in trouble it's a
little bit of a punitive measure oh like
punishment yeah
it is training activities themselves
which have the greatest potential for
wasting a soldier's time
this comes about mainly because of
inadequate planning lack of foresight
and lack of preparedness
soldiers expect to be well trained they
feel shortchanged if they're not
if you're in charge of training people
which if you're in a leadership you are
positioned you are in charge of training
people
and you're wasting your time you are
completely wrong
here's another section i gotta read were
the instructions clear
there is no end of time wasted when one
who is to perform a mission or job is
not fully and clearly instructed
the instructions are misunderstood the
end result
is not what was desired it must be done
over
in fact if things go wrong the leader
in fact when things go wrong the leader
should check first to see
if his instructions were not the cause
it is said that general grant assigned
his adjutant
the mentally slowest officer he could
find
grant read his orders to his adjutant
and if the adjutant could not
understand grant rewarded his orders
until he could
ask yourself are your instructions and
orders so
clear that every man underlined every he
doesn't underline much near every man in
your unit
can understand them when you issue
orders
you are instructing someone remember
that as an instructor
you only teach when someone learns
that's the i always tell that story
about the lowest common denominator
right
it's a matter of fact it's it's in i
think it's in dichotomy
well hey leif and seth i'm telling them
hey i want you to brief
to the lowest common denominator in the
platoon
who whoever you think is going to have
the hardest time brief to your machine
gunners
your new guy machine gunners i want them
to fully understand the plan
i mean that is the entire second law of
combat brief
almost verbatim that he just described
about the plan that's understandable the
way you communicate it
and then to the lowest common
denominator and then to me in my mind
that actually comes back to the comment
he made earlier
which was the effort you got to expend
from your lowest
you know people in the you know the the
the bottom of your
folks for them to understand that that
comedy made before by devoting time to
that
that's the time he's talking about so he
takes this adjutant who
he considers to be of the lowest
intellectual level you know his bottom
third guy and i'll spend as much time as
i need until that guy
gets it yeah and if he gets it we should
we are good to go and so
even pulling that together that comment
made i mean that is
that is simple right there
so good do you fully this is the last
section here
do you fully utilize your soldiers time
i am not optimistic as to believe that
we can eliminate wasting of time as we
have yellow fever
but we can improve our performance in
this regard we can control this problem
by the exercise of sound leadership
techniques among which are planning good
job management issuance of clear
instructions
and thorough follow-up the most valuable
resource available to a commander in the
army is the soldier's time
as leaders we must use this resource to
the best advantage i know of
no better reputation for an officer or
non-commissioned officer to have with
his men
than that he is a good manager and does
not waste his soldiers time
if he has that reputation he will
probably not waste his men's
lives in battle either that that's
powerful uh i've been doing a lot of
talking
about leadership capital on ef online in
fact i've been going kind of berserk
talking about leadership capital on the
f online
and i've been talking about how to build
leadership capital how to lose
leadership capital
and this is one that i haven't mentioned
yet and it's probably one
it's probably a little bit of a blind
spot to me because
i am a freak when it comes to time and
wasting time
and so it's one of those things where i
wouldn't it's so important to me that
i've never
i've never you know walked into a
meeting two hours late to have a bunch
of people waiting around for me to show
up like
that that hasn't that's not happening
but
if you want to expend leadership capital
unnecessarily
and lots of it make people wait around
for you make them waste time
the phrase being late is unacceptable
the reason it's unacceptable is it
because it wastes people's
time you could be the best pilot
in the squadron and if you waste
people's time
you're going to lose leadership capital
you could be
an average pilot and if your reputation
is that
you don't waste people's time they don't
care if you're an average pilot
you actually your leadership capital is
is directly correlated to how you treat
them and how you respect them and how
you respect their time
time wasted was always the it was always
the most frustrating and the most
obvious thing that would happen i think
i've said this on the podcast before
everybody who's had their time wasted by
someone else knows exactly
what that feels like you can think about
it right now sitting around in the
auditorium
sitting around whatever it is that time
of yours that's being
wasted because of somebody else i don't
care how good that somebody else is at
their job their task or anything else if
they are a time
waster you are losing leadership capital
let me ask you this about being late oh
man here we go
i need your opinion what if it's let's
say a halloween party
and they're like hey halloween party you
know there's going to be i don't know
100 people here there's a lot of people
this is a fashionably late scenario
you're getting to
or what have you you know so there's 100
people
invited or whatever 100 plus because
bring who you want if you know it's not
like a guest list you're not invited
it's not that it's just we're having a
party whatever
okay and it starts at i don't know
wasting time how long is this going to
take
it starts at five okay i don't know 5
p.m
okay it goes all night i don't know
whatever
and you're like all right and you get
there it's
6 30. other people are there
but you get there at 6 30. is that
wasting people saying is that bad as far
as being late
if i send you an invitation to my
halloween party and i say the party
starts at five and goes till midnight
i don't care when you show up if i say
echo
be there by seven and you show up at 7
30. is there a difference between those
two
i think so yes yeah but yeah so my
question was more about that first
scenario whatever like if it's like hey
it's
the party starts at five yeah i was
going to say the party starts with or
without you yes
yes super concerned about you yeah
nobody's not nobody's sitting around
waiting for you to get but
exactly contrarily the podcast
starts when you're here so when you're
not here
the podcast doesn't start you're the
ones with the sd
memory cards that go in the little
machines over there
so when you're not here at three o'clock
the pa the party's not starting we're
waiting
i understand you're talking like it's
for real i was here at 2 58 what up you
made it in
yeah it was legit today as much hassle i
give you about hawaiian time
and being late you're not late very
often
no sir do you do you play with fire yes
sir
yeah every day i think and technically a
lot of times there's a minute maybe
maybe
a few you're one of those people if you
set your watch like five minutes fast
you'd probably be on time all the time
yeah if i if i believe it or if i didn't
know i said the what yeah i've done that
before too
well you know i used to tell you like oh
i come from a long line of late people
i remember brought my dad
somebody cracked up because i said like
you got your dna you said you got your
23andme and i said it came back
you got little jesus yes sir
but and you know you kind of look into
it i'm like why am i late or whatever so
because i would
i would go to work late when i used to
work at the club i would be there late
i was there late one minute two minutes
five minutes sometimes probably more
time
than i was on time probably for real i'm
not finding this hard to believe this
doesn't seem like a stress
the thing is technically you are right
like i'm wasting people's time
especially if i if people depend on me
to get there at that time
you know um i'm not getting paid you
know it's the kind you got to clock in
so you're not getting paid
um if you're not there so it's not that
it's like if people were depending on
you to be there but is there like a
briefing
to start the night no negative it's all
independent like
you clock in and you're there i mean it
would piss me off you know i i'd view
you as an unreliable person yeah that i
put no
i put no value in as a human damn
i mean yeah and i dig it
but so i analyzed like why am i like
that
because even if i'm like i need to be
late less you know it just wouldn't
change why am i like
and you should change the statement i
need to be late less
i'm not going to be late yeah you need
to draw a little bit of a
harder line in the sand i
the thing is you're you're right but
when i when i really be truthful it's
because i don't care
about what's going on there you know
like why am i gonna
prepare like take 30 minutes to prepare
this and prepare that for something then
i don't have to be there at that i have
to be there at a certain time so of
course i'm running the risk
in fact if i were to have my way i would
never be late at all
but i would never be early at all either
for things i don't care about you know
like like that i had one time in my life
uh when i was going to college
at and it was really hard to get parking
and eventually i figured out a system
but i had a seal buddy that
he was going to college too and we would
study together and we are but we were
both
on time all the time for everything and
eventually we made a deal
where we gave ourselves like a waiver to
be
five minutes or eight minutes late
because if you were gonna be there at
two o'clock
in order to be there at two o'clock you
had to show up at one
and drive around and so we were just
like you know what hey if you're five
minutes late ten minutes late doesn't
matter
like i don't care i don't want you being
here an hour early
so that you're not one minute late yeah
so we made a little pact
and just said hey bro i'll be there
between 1 and 1 15.
boom all good and i'd try and get there
in one and maybe i get there at 108
maybe he'd get there at 112 or whatever
eventually i figured out i would just
put my bike in the back of the car
and just park at the top of the hill and
just bike no factory yeah see
now you're figuring out how to solve
these problems so on the flip side and
this is all in spirit of getting down to
the whole late thing
because i agree with you at the end of
the day and if you think if you really
be honest like i'm not late
really you know anymore back in
my day yeah yeah i was late yep
what oh are you trying to think of when
i was late no i you were late a little
bit in the beginning but then
but then like it didn't i probably
remember you being late three times
total yeah and this is not not including
a four-minute grace period
which sometimes i think you do just to
just to you know
what do you mean grace period you know
like sometimes if you're supposed to be
here at one you're here at 104.
four minutes late it's possible yeah the
late times i'll tell you hey i'm late
because of this
specific reason or whatever but that's
already but nonetheless
like that is i agree with you where
you're wasting other people's time
people are waiting for you like that's
it's
it's kind of inexcusable in a way
but if you show up
15 minutes early aren't you wasting your
own time a little bit
no because what are you gonna do when
you get there you're gonna prep
yeah well that depends i guess it
depends on who you are sun tzu told us
2500 years ago that the one that shows
up the battlefield first
wins yeah you know as far as
battlefields go for sure
um but certain circumstances
if you're there let's say okay hey i'm
gonna meet you for brunch
you know what's in my bag right now
oh i could probably uh the next book i'm
reading on the podcast when i show up
here early
if there's no one here cool i get to
read i get to get ahead oh yeah
okay so that's a good point okay yes
question answered because yeah if you
show up fit and you got to be thinking i
guess at the end of the day
so if you show up 15 minutes early
you're not wasting your time because you
can still choose what to do
you're not forced to wait around for not
waiting yeah
you should be proactively making
something happen yeah and you have that
option
i mean technically i guess if you're
waiting for someone you have that option
but like
they're putting you in that position
rather than you making the decision
putting yourself in that position
potentially
i understand i understand
back to the book chapter 16. so i was
super fired up when i read this chapter
title
and then be honest with you i got a
little less fired up when i got into it
but because the chapter is
will you wait for it or will
you go get it i was like oh damn
this is the chapter i've been waiting
for but
what he's talking about is information
i'm still fired up for gathering
information and are you gonna wait for
information to come to you are you gonna
go get it i'm still
i'm so fired up about it but i'm not as
fired up as i was it's just like you're
just gonna make things happen
but uh he goes in here there's more than
one school of thought concerning how a
commander can
acquire reliable information
one school contends that the commander
should analyze reports that come to him
from his subordinate units and staff the
other advocates that the commander
should go see here for himself yet
another endorses a combination of these
methods
as a commander from company to army
group and an observer
of others holding such positions in
three wars
that's got to feel a little bit cool to
write
i have come to certain conclusions
myself moreover since my
retirement from the army i have worked
as a consultant to research
organizations making studies of command
control and communication problems for
the army
the result of this active and retired
experience might be helpful to students
and practitioners
who should who would like to excel in
the art and techniques of commandership
in generalship
and then he goes here looking back it
seems to me
more than ever that my best information
on both
our own forces and the enemies was
obtained by visiting
or observing subordinate commanders so
there you go i guess he's saying go get
it
this is done either by jeep or
fixed-wing airplane borrowed from the
artillery small radios
he goes on he says this
as a core commander in korea with five
divisions on the line
i often left my headquarters by chapter
by chopper after morning staff briefing
and i visited the five division
headquarters in turn from left to right
the divisions knew when i was coming the
division commanders were told
that they need not wait for me and that
i would talk to the chiefs of staff
over a cup of coffee we discussed the
latest situations
then we discussed the problems which had
been presented
by them on a previous day then i noted
what they wanted my core headquarters to
do to help them
so that's all good he's gathering
information and then he says i told them
the situation of the eighth army
and of the i-corps as i knew it
so not only is he out there receiving
information he is telling them what is
going on
so and he ends up saying that he that he
did that
and it's funny i was i was i was reading
this and he says uh
generally the next day i repeated this
as a result i was not only the core
commander but the core commander liaison
officer and to a large extent the core
communicator with the lower units and i
put in parentheses when i was reading
this
it was a static war because at this
point korea
you know it was it was almost trench
warfare like they weren't moving
and then what's interesting fast forward
a little bit says this was in a static
situation but such command techniques
are not
unusable in mobile warfare so
get out there get that information um
he's got this section in here history is
full of instances where the commander
being at the critical point at the
critical time
turned the tide of battle to victory or
conversely the commander not being
on scene his force was defeated few such
examples have been related so
dramatically
as in the poem sheridan's ride by thomas
buchanan and reed
so we're talking civil war we're talking
general
philip sheridan
union general who was five foot five
we were talking about height a little
bit earlier well he was known as
little phil also known as fighting phil
and the battle of cedar creek october 19
1864 is when this went down
one will recall that early in the
morning sheraton was at
winchester virginia 20 miles away from
his command
when news of a new battle arrived
he mounted his horse and took off at
full speed for the field
of combat reed's stirring verse traces
sheridan's progress through five stanzas
stanzas giving equal credit to both him
and his horse the sixth stanza shows
what happens when the commander arrives
at the critical point of battle
and at a critical time quote the first
the general saw were the groups of
stragglers
and then the retreating troops what was
done
what to do a glance told him both
then striking his spurs with a terrible
oath he dashed down the line made a
storm of huzzas
which i had to look up that's an old
form of hooray
so the people started
and the wave of retreat checked its
course there because
the sight of the master compelled it to
pause
so there you go the commander shows up
on the battlefield and he turns this
retreat into an advance and they ended
up kind of smashing the confederates
in that battle it's it is
inconceivable that the same result could
have been attained on an automated
battlefield
nor could sheridan have been brought
could have nor
could sheridan have brought order out of
chaos while seated
before a display panel 20 miles away you
need to get there
need to get there and then he talks
about
why commanders should be
forward
he talks about the the like computer
stuff and
and again he's writing this this
originally came out i think in 1963
and then this version was 1973. so
he's talking about computers so
god only knows what that consisted of a
of like a mobile command computer
oh we need to get a we i need to do some
research on that one
and he says these are fine until
disorderly and confusing conditions
uh that occur so often in battle
materialize they do not realize the
roles of
judgment so he's talking about all these
computations and these things that they
set up
and he's saying once those are those are
cool when everything's cool but then
once the mayhem happens
they do not realize the roles of the
judgment and experience factors which
must be used in handling tactical battle
reports
inevitably these lead to a working
principle
such as and so here here's here's what
the commanders are using to judge their
information
when they're using computer-based data
discount by 50 all very favorable or
unfavorable
operational reports which come into your
headquarters from your subordinate units
and then question the remainder so it's
basically like this
just junk it's just junk
and then he talks about the helicopter
and using that to
stay forward which is effective as well
he's got this
whole this whole chapter adp in war
will it work it's automatic
data processing so we're not going to
cover much of this
and he sets up this sort of hypothetical
situation where he starts asking a bunch
of questions
about how well this 80 how well it's
going to work to use adp
during war and a lot of this
you know he's he's literally talking
about like are there going to be power
sources available so it's really kind of
nitty nitty-gritty stuff
but then he says i wouldn't i would not
be honest with you if i did not point
out
that commanders at all echelons are
apprehensive of the tendency to use
adp to facilitate centralization of
command and control
i can foresee disastrous effects from
indiscriminate
from indiscriminate centralization or
over centralization
and loss of flexibility in modern fluid
war
why is that because now all of a sudden
the leader can track everything that
everyone's doing hey like dave's in his
aircraft and he's like wait a second go
a little bit further to the right go a
little bit further to the left we know
exactly where you are
wait don't drop the bomb yet okay drop
it now and we're trying to micromanage
will adp cause the commander to be more
command post
bound and thus reduce his ability to be
at critical points
at critical times until that ended up
being a yes
with its increased speed and capacity
for information will adp
in the hands of staff officers or of
higher headquarters
tend to encourage them to put increased
burden of reporting on lower echelons
who are often busily engaged in the
vital conduct of battle
how crazy is that dave it's nuts
picturing what i saw
you know from the talk and the in the
command center you know picturing this
being 19
what was 76 where you said yes the
answer that question is yes it will
yeah so that's what happened in the
military all of a sudden we have the
ability to get information so we're
going to require
the information we're going to want more
of it and you're going to demand it at a
time that is
totally incompatible with when they
should be giving you the information
they want to know what's going on yeah
right well the reason you don't know
what's going on is i'm in the middle of
doing something right now yeah
i got a little situation i'm trying to
handle yeah
yeah so that's that's how he uh explains
the whole
adp thing um
chapter 18 making progress and improving
a military organization it is the aim of
anyone who is privileged to command a
company battalion brigade or division to
leave in it is
to leave it in much better shape than he
found it and to be sure
his superiors recognize that fact
and he goes through this little pluses
mess method which he's gone through
before one of the earlier podcasts which
you're gonna make little
little incremental changes to get better
he goes over this section about
protecting your image as a commander a
word about headlines most commanders who
have sought
headlines to establish their image and
i'm using those uh those
he's putting those in quotes in the
minds of their men
and their superiors have soon or later
have been plagued by unfavorable
headlines
produce a superior well-rounded and
solid unit and your image as a commander
will be secure
as will your military future
and then this is the this is the last
thing that we are going to
cover i think oh no it's not not yet not
quite there though
yeah it is all right so chapter 19
techniques of troop orientation and
informed education
one of the most important duties of a
commander is to keep his troops informed
and oriented
this is done in many different ways with
varying degrees of effectiveness
a technique i found very effective was
to inform an
orient by posters and personal visits
so he's talking about posters literally
posters that you hang on the wall
and this is why when you were talking
about simplicity earlier dave
this is this is kind of knocking out of
the park and when i said
earlier on this podcast when i was
giving him a grade of a
d minus for his simplicity of language
and his opening
he makes up for it here with these
posters
in 1956 i took command of the seventh
u.s army
in europe at a time when the
relationship of the troops with their
german neighbors
was at a low ebb due to a number of
things i think this is also when
hackworth was working for him
after studying the situation i concluded
that the transition from
an army of occupation to the status of a
guest army
in a host nation had not been
accomplished so there's the wrong
culture
there's the wrong culture from from
occupation status to like
host to to a guest to a host nation
this is in germany so we went in there
we're occupying force these were our
enemies and now all of a sudden we're
saying all right that's not the deal
anymore
now they're the host nation and we're
the guests
so he's can you imagine trying to shift
that culture that's a tough culture
shift
i set out to bring about this transition
not only for the soldiers but for the
dependents and u.s civilian employees in
germany
and so he comes up with this poster that
the poster is called
soldier and the soul the poster just has
this
picture of a soldier who looks badass
and it says soldier
this is why you're in germany
and it's got bullet points to play your
part
on the nato team to help maintain peace
by being constantly combat ready
to be a good neighbor to our german
neighbors
to fight if necessary for the rights of
free men
in the world
simplicity score dave what are you
giving him
that's a significant improvement over
the years
award big time most improved award
so so very obvious so that's what he did
he made this poster and
and then he did these visits he did
these visits where
he would take the troops and and send
them to
check out what was happening at the
berlin wall
so it's another way to make people
understand why
and not only would he send the troops
but he would if he could send the
dependents there as well
so they understood why you go see the
berlin wall
and then he made and this is the last
thing we're going to cover
again he's making this so simple and so
clear
so along with that campaign to get
people to see the wall to understand
what the purpose of being there was to
understand
why we were there he made this poster
there's a couple pictures of
the wall and it says why
and it says have you ever wondered
why must the communists build walls and
fences to keep people from
fleeing the land where they were born
why must they charge their fences with
electricity
which can kill people who try to escape
why
armed guards along these walls and
fences
shoot and kill their own people who try
to escape
from their homes why
despite these walls and fences and guns
have over 4 million people left their
homes
property and friends and risked their
lives to escape
in the past 15 years why
the communists surround themselves with
walls
and fences when history shows that this
has
often been the first step in the
self-destruction
of an empire
and then he says why why were these
effectives these posters
and operation look-see which was
actually traveling to the berlin wall
were effective
because they used the most efficient
techniques of
of informing and orienting the soldier
and of having his commander tell him in
basic
and simple terms about situations which
are close to him
and affect or could affect him
personally
he gets it across as simply as possible
so there you go that is the that wraps
up our review
of guidelines for the leader and
commander i have initiated
the publication through jockle
publishing of this book we are reaching
out to try and figure out what what
needs to happen there
uh but it's underway bozak has it for
action
so we'll get it out we'll get it
published um i'm sure
that we will continue to refer to it
there's so many good lessons here even
that last lesson
the these posters were effective because
they
used the most simple terms to explain
to the soldiers why they were doing what
they're doing something that i've been
talking about for 20 years
explaining people why they're doing what
they're doing and that is such an
awf that's such an such a it's a
response we use all the time at
salonfront
all the time my people aren't doing this
my people ca
my people don't want to get on board
with that tell them why they're doing
what they're doing explain it to them in
terms that they can understand
that's what he did that's what he's
telling us to do
telling us to be more effective telling
us to be more efficient telling us to
not waste time
telling us to be in good physical
condition
and to strive always remember what he
said
you're never a hundred percent combat
effective you never get there
you always have to strive to be better
so thank you general clark for that
echo charles yes sir uh speaking of
getting better
mm-hmm or at least always trying to get
better striving to get better
too yes do we have any recommendations
on
you know making that happen yes we do
dave
we do i just saw dave look at his watch
yep he's just looking at his watch
thinking all right
i know i have work to do you know what's
you know what's funny you know what
i know dave has work to do i know i have
one
yeah i know there's one person
i'm not saying they don't have work to
do but they might have less work to do
they might have a less
of a stringent timeline to follow well
you did say
might because you know you never do know
okay all right all right okay
good job getting better all the work i
have to do i'll tell you part of the
work i have to do is
inform my people our people all right
let's do it
on how to get through or should i say
move forward on this path we're all on
boom we're working out we're taking jiu
jitsu if we can
we're reading we're surrounding
ourselves with
good people it's a sliding scale i
understand
nonetheless these are things we're
trying to do
on this path we need supplementation
don't worry jocko has fuel it's called
jocko fuel supplementation for your
whole body all the way up to your brain
the last cell in your brain anyway what
we got joint warfare
we got your morphine i told you my wife
has an injury not anymore
feeding her joint warfare she's on her
feet that's what i'm talking about
oh yeah every day so joint warfare super
krill oil
these are for your joints free bones
keep yourself in the game don't even
have to worry about them anymore you
take this stuff
also we have discipline which is
for your brain ish it's not just for
your brain that's what i'm saying
true for your body too so discipline
discipline go
and then discipline go in the can it's
all the same family
we'll say is that accurate way to put it
accurate
it's true yeah a little note on
discipline go
in the cans so
look are we at war
yes i would say yes i mean from a
business sense we're at war
we've had we've been attacked we had an
act let's just say this at a minimum
we've had an act of war
against us a another
very large energy drink
company has spotted
an insurgency happening they didn't like
it
they're trying to maneuver to shut down
some of our manufacturing but guess who
had contingency planning
yes us but where war so right now hey we
are in wawa in florida
we want to be all over the east coast in
wawa and then we want to hit the rest of
the stores across the country
if you're in florida go to wawa
get some go try some go what flavors
do you recommend dave yeah
all of them let me ask you this are you
how how many are you
have you drank one flavor enough where
you shifted to another flavor
like i've done that with milk where i'll
go on mulk i'll go on mint milk for
three weeks then all of a sudden i'm
like oh that's strawberry but right now
i'm on that pumpkin
i'm on that smashing pumpkin pumpkin
spice
that stuff is crazy good so have you
have you gone you go do you rotate daily
are you doing random out of the box what
are you doing
i i try to go random out of the box or
out of the fridge
i try to go random out of the fridge i
have not done that the last
seven days because you're just straight
dude i am straight
afterburner orange that's what i'm right
now so my
my older two daughters kind of speak
their own
language and one of the words that
they've been
using a lot lately is if something is
very good
then it's a fantasy and they say it in
various
funny ways but then they've shortened it
to say
fant oh that's a fant
and so the other day my middle daughter
took a drink of afterburner orange and
she said
oh that's a fant like a fanta
so there you go there's a little yeah
like orange fanta right literally
orange fan i'm gonna have to agree with
that one the orange the after
burner orange yeah that's the kind of
the number one right now it's good
factually i'm still just just jocko
palmer all day
yeah and i understand i i've i will have
probably for every four jocko palmer i
will have
one orange or one sour apple sniper
maybe a dax savage even though jack
savage people like my wife's dax savage
all day
yeah i could see that sometimes i just
want to get a little
like dakota meyer mindset sure just go
get something
that can just that that can is legit
yeah sure yeah
yes sir but yes so yes
discipline energy drink essentially
i said it yeah i said what i said energy
drinkish
health and it's a health energy drink
it's real energy is what it is
it's real energy yeah so nonetheless
yes these are the supplementation
elements that we can
call upon on this path
also jack you mentioned milk so you got
all these different flavors of malt
protein in the form of a dessert you
just made it a smashing pumpkin i'm with
it i'm with the smashing pumpkin oh it's
good
what about kid approved too oh yeah kids
kids are
all over that it was declared
a uh full fantasy in my house fantasy
is that my daughter's declared smashing
pumpkin a full fantasy full fantasy okay
i'm gonna kind of remember that see if
it sticks well actually i don't know if
i won't do that nonetheless it does
sound cool
when you say that your daughters say it
but you can't start
bringing no i i can tell you that i
won't start calling things
like oh that move in ufc was a full
fantasy
yes thank you it's not really gonna flow
no
probably not so speaking of full fantasy
oh that was cool
yeah stick with cool speaking of cool
and full fantasy choco yt
is also out there another light
refreshing
element that we haven't spent that much
time talking about but that's fine it's
still out there and it's still going
strong
of course um you can get that in a can
as well
right you can get all this stuff at
origenmaine.com you can get it at
the vitamin shop nationwide you can get
it at
wawa florida this is what what is it
right now it's uh november
hopefully we'll get that whole east
coast ticket now look when i posted that
we were in wawa the other day everyone's
all fired up and like okay
what about 7-eleven what about amp and
what local that's the goal
like i said florida's a little bit of a
battleground state
yeah so we hope yeah you know when you
you're hoping
but people in florida will get after it
yeah fully wait is jacqueline t in wawa
or just
the discipline yep yeah okay well there
you go
boom also at origin main.com you can get
this stuff also at urgemaine.com you can
get other stuff jujitsu stuff
geez rash guards uh some various you
know whether it be workout clothes
clothing shirts
but on top of that american-made denim
jeans also did you get new deltas no not
yet
okay did you get new deltas yeah
so the new deltas they're freaking legit
and yeah they're just
the old deltas i thought were the best
thing that you could put on your legs
but now the the new deltas which if
you're ordering deltas now they're the
new deltas
and they're freaking the best thing ever
and they're what they're kind of um
like stretchy-ish i mean obviously
they're not
they do have stretch to them
that way when you throw that full
fantasy roundhouse kick
you're good okay you're not ripping your
pants yeah that's good for sure
okay well there you have it full fantasy
stuff
um yeah jeans boots all american-made
stuff this is a big deal
and and i think we all know that and we
all know why
also we have our own store
yeah i said it i said what i said all
right it's still jocko's store so that
thing what you just said
i said what i said yeah you know that's
kind of a thing too right
from i yeah i don't know okay that's
another thing that my daughters are
saying
okay older dogs i like that one i think
it's very funny they'll be like i said
what i said
there was this joke like you know the
neither the memes online
there's this joke that it was like i
forget even the joke but it was
it was really funny and since since then
i started i appreciate memes
oh yeah i appreciate memes and i even
appreciate people that have
you know like a hat that says veteran of
the meme wars and they have
they've awarded they've been awarded
whatever awards you get for the maybe
they got a nam
with five five names
so yeah i the memes are good yes
i agree but somehow i don't
the memes don't flow to me it's always
my son that shows me memes
yeah i don't know what the hell he
subscribes to
graham as you call it but he shows me
some memes that are funny yeah they're
really funny
yeah whoever's making it they're smart
people like you know how you can you
know some
jokes are like bro that's like not even
it's like a cheap
joke that's not funny and then some are
like you got to be whoever thought of
that made that joke up
he's like a smart funny person right you
know like
there's some impressive stuff on there
for real like i i
inadvertently well or advertently
whatever
subscribe to like a bunch of them it's
really good that's really good
and yeah full grown man fully memes all
day
um but yes i said what i said it's our
store
okay it's still called jocko store so
anyway yes jacqueline store this is
where you can represent
with clothing t-shirts hoodies
discipline equals freedom
good all this stuff here's the thing i
said this last week and say it again
it's a big deal
we have a t-shirt club okay so this is
what the t-shirt club kinda
is it's like okay look the t-shirt club
is
echo coming up with a lot of different
t-shirts and me saying
dude we can't make a million different
t-shirts
because how we gonna keep a million
different t-shirts
in stock yeah and how many and all that
stuff
yeah and then you come up with a big
creative idea
yes that well you know i guess good
credit it depends
you had the end state in mind yeah right
you figured a way to solve that problem
well i think it's good because also on
top of that
which um yes that's true but on top of
it it's like sometimes
like even you'll be like hey put this on
a t-shirt or i'll be like oh you know
like suggesting like a t-shirt and it's
a good it's fun it's a fun
good idea or cool or cool because let's
face it you come up with ideas for
t-shirts that are
fun and i come up with ideas for
t-shirts that are cool
oh yeah super cool extra okay
are you denying about that no no no no
no all good it's true
it's 100 true actually but
we can't just start like you said just
throwing these shirts on like or
whatever but the idea of
you know so these ideas for shirts that
they they're they're doable
also people the people always say can
you make this t-shirt can you make that
t-shirt that'd be a cool t-shirt
yeah and there's some that i'm like that
are shirts so we talk about
and then someone hey you should do this
shirt be like yeah we just talked about
that kind of thing you know
so it's like all these ideas hey we'll
throw it in one month we'll have it you
know you can
have it and it just goes on and on it's
good a little subscription situation
anyway
it's a good t-shirt club real fun okay
so because you're
kind of kind of just giving me a look
when i said i come up with cool t-shirt
ideas
i'm gonna say one that will be available
through the t-shirt what is it
subscription
sure yeah so here's one uh
podcast number 53 there's one part this
is the chosen
reservoir we're talking about the book
colder than hell and there's one point
where the marines
are fighting for their lives
and they're assaulting down a hill
and there's a guy the guy that's writing
the book is writing what he's seeing and
he sees these guys getting up and
charging and one of the marines
is not holding a gun he's holding a
freaking axe
and he's charging at the chinese
communists
and assaults their position
and so that's what i want to put it on a
t-shirt a silhouette
somehow of a crazy picture where you can
tell
that there is a marine with an axe
running down assaulting a communist
position
and all it's gonna say is on that is
like
colder than hell podcast 53 that's it
you know i want that t-shirt yeah i
agree that is actually
dave impressively awesome that's a cool
shirt
boom because she'll be approved i agree
so
anyway yes so you know stuff like that
anyway check it out if you want it's
that's on dracostore.com
as well also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already
you don't i mean i don't know don't
subscribe subscribe right that's the
thing
it'd be cool if you subscribe yeah that
way you're listening to it yeah so
yourself we're making them
yeah we're probably making them faster
and you can listen to them which is
interesting possible yeah yes you are
because
you have we have taco podcast
yep the unraveling podcast well that's
that's on a different thread now by the
way someone just contacted
a different thread yeah they're like hey
you you haven't unloaded unraveling
whatever you know you said you did
here's the thing
it's a different thread so you gotta
look for it or whatever so it's called
the unraveling
it's actually called the jocko
unraveling podcast
so search for jocko unraveling and
you'll find it it's daryl cooper and me
talking about me i've been listening to
him they're freaking legit
it's it's it's awesome so check that one
out we also have the grounded podcast
which we haven't recorded one in months
you know because we've been on
quarantine so we haven't had oh wait
we haven't recorded ground grounded
podcasts so we'll we'll knock on those
and i know i owe warrior kid and i got
warrior kid 4 coming out so we'll get
some warrior kid ones done as well we
got a youtube channel
if you want to see echo's videos that
he's super proud of
where he makes a bunch of stuff blow up
and whatever
sometimes or with airplanes whichever
yeah it's good also the video version
podcast by the way if you want to see
what good deal dave burke
looks like yeah yeah nonetheless yes
youtube channel
good you can see good outlet yeah
subscribe to that one did you say we're
like official or whatever on there
official yeah we're oh yeah yeah yeah so
yeah that's how you can tell that that's
the real one so
it's just jockle podcast yeah youtube
channel all good
boom also psychological debrief podcast
did we say it oh yeah no we didn't okay
yes debrief podcast jocko and dave burke
chaco's reading my notes yeah i can see
you know i see you write something i'm
like oh wait a second
we got another podcast but it comes out
on this thread we haven't broken it out
yet onto another thread i don't know if
we will
maybe maybe not we'll see what happens
but anyways it's
really it's us talking about what we do
at echelon front working with clients
and it's just all
it's like 100 leadership right it's a
leadership injection in directly into
your veins there's no
there's no books to be read they're
shorter they're like half an hour 45
minutes yeah
would you call it like a case analysis
kind of situation some of them are cases
now
some are just lessons learned oh yeah
feel you know what it's like uh
it's like some of those books that that
i've covered actually i've been covering
them recently those direct reports from
combat
from world war ii they're like this is
an interview we want to get this
information to the troops as quickly as
possible
that's what the debrief it's a freaking
debrief it's dave and i debriefing
what we do on a daily basis to help
companies
and help leaders lead their companies so
that's what the debrief podcast is
yep also psychological warfare it's an
album with tracks
jacquard getting helping you pass your
moments of weakness straight up in
whatever capacity that you might
run into moments of weakness uh flipside
canvas
dakota myers company making cool stuff
to hang on your walls that will keep you
on the path written a bunch of books and
got a bunch of books uh we got a book
called about face
i wrote the forward for that it's by
hackworth this whole series of
whatever we just did six podcasts about
guidelines for the leader commander
i found that through about face which is
my favorite book which i wrote the
forward too so you can check that out
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
we got the code the evaluation the
protocols we got the new edition of the
discipline equals freedom field manual
this is the christmas new year's gift
book this is what your people want wrong
am i right you're correct i'm correct
uh a bunch of new material in there it's
like something like 40
new pages in there and if someone you
know
wants to get on the path back on the
path needs to get on the path
if you want to stay on the path get him
that new version of the discipline
equals freedom
field manual got way of the warrior kid
four
field manual coming out how the kids
liking it dave my kids are so stoked on
that
that's one section that they really like
oh right on
right on uh that's good there's
let's just say there's layers in the
book layers we'll say that there's
layers
so weigh the warrior kid four field
manual um
young mark meets a kid like last day of
school the kid wants to be a warrior kid
but he's leaving he hasn't said anything
because he's shy
he comes up and says oh mark i really
wanted to hang out with you and your
friends and be a warrior kid like
you but i'm leaving i'm moving and so
mark goes home last day of school now
uncle jake's there and he says ah you
know i met this kid he wanted to be a
warrior kid but i can't help him
and uncle jake of course says yes you
can you're going to write them a field
manual
what's that it's instructions on how to
be a warrior kid
so that's what the book is weigh the
warrior kid for field manual don't
forget about where your kid weigh the
work at one two and three
don't forget about miking the dragons
and of course don't forget about extreme
ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership don't
forget that i have a
consulting company leadership
consultancy
we solve problems through leadership
whatever problems you have in your
organization
it's a leadership problem and what we do
is we solve those
problems through leadership go to
ashlandfront.com for details go to ef
online if you want to ask me a question
if you want to ask dave a question
live we will be sitting there answering
your questions
if you want to go deeper on the
materials that we talk about we have
video courses on there so check out
efonline.com
we only have one muster in 2020.
it's in dallas texas december 3rd and
4th go to extremeownership.com for
details
this is our leadership conference where
we
get granular where we interact
where we explain these principles so you
can take them
and make your business and your life
better we have efoverwatch.com
if you need executive leadership inside
your company you need
middle management inside your company
you want people that understand the
principles that we talk about here go to
eforewatch.com
and if you want to help service members
if you want to help active duty people
you want to help retired people you want
to help their families you want to help
gold star families around the world
then check out mark lee's mom's charity
organization
mama lee she has an organization called
america's mightywarriors.org
you can check that out if you want to
donate or if you want to get involved
and if you
let's say you want more pain you just
want more pain we can deliver
you can get more of my distressing
diatribes
you can get more of echo's misplaced
monologues
and obviously you can get some more of
dave's
concentrated confabulations
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on instagram which echo will only refer
to as
the gram and on that face
dave is at david r burke echoes that
echo charles and i am at jacqueline and
thanks
to general bruce clark and colonel david
hackworth
for passing these lessons on to us
and for your service to this great
nation and to everyone out there in
uniform
thank you for standing the watch and for
keeping us safe and also
to police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service
thanks to all of you for standing the
watch here at home
and everyone else out there
remember this one thing from general
bruce c clark
an hour lost today is an
hour lost forever
don't waste time it is running out
and with that until next time this is
dave
and echo and jocko out